this Saturday was pretty wild me and
Luke were out at Whole Foods I was
grabbing a nice little little quarter
lobster bisque when I get a message that
Elon Musk is live on Twitter spaces
talking about what was going on the
Twitter files the the things the
government has been accused of doing in
terms of censorship and election
interference just really crazy stuff and
uh one of them I'm walking around Whole
Foods and I got this like phone up to my
ear listening to this crazy conversation
when Elon Musk said something to the
effect of if I commit suicide it's not
real because people were talking about
the the real threat to his life because
of what he's doing
well we have two things one I mean I
think that's the the big story uh Elon
Musk was getting in a car and he said
I'm not doing any public signings ever
again he's got security surrounding uh
surrounding him he talks about how the
threat of assassination is real
and I think that's really interesting
and it's also interesting how the media
has been putting out this generic
message of PR for the richest man in the
world all identical like puppets giving
being given marching orders is very
strange
the crazy thing is the story itself
Matt taibi I think did a great job but
he made a big mistake in the Twitter
files if you didn't see it on Friday
they basically revealed that the
Democratic National Committee uh was
reach out to Twitter for favors to take
content down
now in one of the tweets Matt typey said
he didn't see evidence that government
was involved however Jack besobic
followed up with an FEC document showing
the head of site trust or whatever Joel
Roth saying that he had been reached out
to by the FBI that there would be hacked
information coming to the platform to be
disseminated and it would involve Hunter
Biden this means the government did go
to the highest level of Twitter tell
them to take it down the Twitter files
then expose
that they had no real justification for
blocking the story but decided to do it
anyway and now we see the big cover-up
so we'll talk about that we'll get into
greater detail I want to rehash the
whole story but the other news is
what else is rather interesting and
there's a lot of uh interesting
questions about it but I think I should
talk about it around 7 A.M this morning
two men broke into my house and uh don't
know exactly why or what was happening
there's a lot of speculation I don't
want to reveal too many details but a
shot was fired by one of uh I'll just
I'll keep it very vague for law
enforcement reasons not by them they the
the burglars we don't know what they
were looking for what was happening
entirely possible it was random I kind
of don't think so considering you can't
mistake this property when you get on it
and everything that's happening there
and uh uh uh after nearly being struck
they Dove out the window panicked fled
and uh left behind a wallet with an ID
in it
so the whole thing is very very weird
considering what's going on in politics
I figured you know maybe we should talk
about this and the threats that we've
received the next story we have is that
there's a substation uh shot up in North
Carolina knocking out power on the left
is claiming it was Far Right Wingers
trying to shut down a drag performance
show so we got to talk about this stuff
it's it's a crazy it's a crazy uh Monday
I suppose before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member
click that join us button to support our
work directly and you'll get access to
the uncensored members only show we put
up Monday through Thursday as well as
the cast Castle Vlog Tales from the
inverted world and uh more content to
come we've got a documentary on gun
rights coming out soon and we actually
have a behind the scenes with yay from
last week if you guys want to see it
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends if you really do like it joining
us today to talk about all of this is
Chef Andrew gruel
thank you so much it's an honor to be
here absolutely who are you what do you
do all right Andrew gruel uh I am uh
chef and restaurant tour some people
might know me from being on Food Network
shows or having a series on FYI Network
some other TV stuff or from one of my
restaurants
um I started with a food truck in 2011
grew to 40 plus restaurants recently
sold slap fish which was kind of my
namesake restaurant still have six
Concepts I'm from Southern California
Huntington Beach specifically I'm a
father of four and a husband and that is
my life in a nutshell right on it should
be interesting to uh to talk about you
you uh called out California over the
lockdown stuff which uh while it was
contentious to say the least yeah it
didn't I mean you know it depends on how
you look at it whether it went over well
or didn't go over well but without
getting into too much of the granular
detail I'll say this I did speak out
about uh Newsome's hypocritical
lockdowns and the state immediately
turned on me but uh you know the good
news here is is that as I continued to
speak out and doing so rationally right
it wasn't anything crazy extreme our
sales doubled tripled the support came
flying in there uh as that support came
in we decided to start a fund I called
86 restaurant struggle we actually ended
up raising over a half million dollars
for struggling and out of work
restaurant workers not small business
owners but restaurant workers at the
time
um more no less than four months after I
raised that half a million dollars I did
do a piece on Tucker Carlson and then
antifa quickly turned on me for being an
anti-worker uh uh mouthpiece which I
think is funny when you contrast that
against raising all the money but uh you
know so I've been up and down that
California roller coaster and everything
post pandemic so uh lots to talk about
right on right on Luke's here definitely
expect some questions about bugs and
Seed oils in the future uh that's on the
show my name is lucrative here of we are
change.org and I live by two principles
don't take people's stuff and don't hurt
them a principle that of course the
government does the exact opposite of
and I think we should definitely be
sharing more of these principles and
spreading them and if you agree with
that you could get that message which is
on my shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
guys do that that's why I'm here thank
you again so much for having me I'm the
wizard The Sorcerer I'm not sure which
one I'm better at Wizardry or sorcery
but ones with your intelligence the
Wizardry the other ones with your
charisma the sorcery I don't know you
let me know I'm looking forward to
talking to you about what's that I said
is that what that is yeah Sorcerers use
their Charisma to cast magic they have
less choices of magics they can use but
they're very refined at what they do
whereas Wizards use their knowledge and
understanding of nature to manipulate
and use it so like they'll use like a
like yeah we'll get into it later on the
show what's up dude I'm glad I want to
hear all about your perspective on how
you dealt with the pandemic as a
restaurant here obviously but hopefully
we can go deep into just the magic of
restauranteering General Food you know
what it's like to own restaurants maybe
later in the episode I'll start asking
you questions awesome peace out and I am
search.com adserve.com thanks guys for
getting my answer number 2K that was
cool feeling give me a little dopamine
bump there you go appreciate it all
right everybody let's talk about this
first story Elon Musk claims risk of his
assassination is quite significant and
uh a little bit more than that he said
quote if I committed suicide it's not
real as soon as I heard him say that I
had to tweet it out when he was
releasing the Twitter files he said it
was going to be at 5 PM then all of a
sudden he's like okay it's gonna be in
an hour then he goes dark and everyone's
like what's happening the joke across
Twitter was last minute phone call from
Hillary Clinton aha
so he says frankly the risk of something
bad happening to me or even literally
being shot is quite significant it's not
that hard to kill somebody if you wanted
to so hopefully they don't and fate fate
Smiles upon the situation with me and it
does not happen there's definitely some
risk there
I I gotta say the first thing is uh does
that seem like the typical reaction from
someone who genuinely feels like they'll
lose their life and I'm not saying he's
wrong or that's not true I'm saying I
guess you'd expect him to wreck
differently right Abe Lincoln had a
similar thing where he was just like
they wanted him to have all the security
was like you know what if they kill me
they kill me and he had a dream a few
nights before he was killed of him
walking through the White House people
were crying in his dream he was like
what happened they were like the
president's been killed and then he woke
up Lincoln and he was like what that was
weird a couple days later he was shot
and killed so once I think if you're at
peace with yourself you just have to be
your best self and damn be the
consequences but
you know I mean what like he said if
everyone in the world wants to kill you
how long can you survive I mean seven
minutes I don't think it's everyone I
think it's a certain select few of
individuals some of them uh you know
rhyming with uh Hillary you know sorry
he just literally said Hillary pardon
part of my friendship but I think
there's another area yeah chillery you
know but I think there's a reason uh
Epstein was trending Friday night when
we had the delay of the Twitter files I
think we're living in a society where
intelligence agencies do have things
like heart attack guns and if you look
at these latest Twitter files who did
they go after the intelligence agencies
that we know were Conjuring up lies in
order to try to push a narrative and a
story and to suppress a story that would
make a political party look uh good when
of course the reality of it was that
they were bad that there was a lot of
horrible things you want to say
something I just want to pull I want to
confirm the source of uh this is from
all all that's interesting.com the heart
attack gunfighter Dart made from Frozen
shellfish toxin that would enter the
target's bloodstream and kill them in
mere minutes without leaving a trace
it's like in the 60s or 70s
1975. that was yeah through the I think
the commission hearings uh the Warren
Commission hearings I believe if I stand
corrected that there was uh a lot of
disclosure with what the intelligence
agencies were doing uh behind the scenes
and this is this is decades and decades
ago you can only imagine what they have
now so with Elon Musk saying that he's
taking his security uh you know more
significantly uh taking taken his
security more seriously than before I
mean obviously he's pissing off a lot of
powerful people that do
Epstein people let's just be real here
let's just be honest here with ourselves
you know one thing that I often thought
about with stuff like this in Trump I
heard that one thing I've heard we've
talked about the reason Trump likes fast
food so much is that when you walk into
a McDonald's the Burger's already made
so when you order it they can't tamper
with it and there's like a fear I don't
know if that's true but that's a gross
excuse to eat McDonald's I just I it's
but it makes sense but yeah logical I
mean I worry about this stuff like you
never know we live in country so for the
most part people come out fist bump me
and they're really excited you know like
I don't but I I'm if I go into like a
deep blue area where people are you know
crazy leftists or whatever I gotta worry
about my food getting messed with or
something
food is the Avenue through which they
typically do something like this which
is why we run a tight ship in my
kitchens but uh you know it's funny when
I hear that about the shellfish and my
this is how sick my mind is I
immediately go to like braised shellfish
with garlic and white wine and herbs and
all of that uh uh you know with the Elon
piece of this I think two things number
one kind of Heisenberg's principle which
I think I'm using this properly right
the act of observation ultimately
affects that of which is being observed
so if he goes out there and throws this
out into the public you know that act
right and then under the observation he
could change the trajectory so get it
out there talk about it let it be public
and then ultimately that that could
hypothetically change uh whether you
know however you want to look at this
change what's going to happen number two
he's a businessman at heart right and
the more he talks the more he puts out
these kind of hyperbolic statements the
more people are going to go on Twitter
more people they're going to Tweet about
it I mean he's driving business by
virtue of his own narrative and it's
kind of brilliant because we see the
numbers we see the activity is up and
and that that ticks everybody off
because they talk about how oh well
Twitter's gonna shut down this weekend
yeah and now the headlines came out
after he he published and produced how
successful Twitter was over the past
three to four weeks well that's just a
smoke screen those are going to go down
and just the correction it was the
church hearings that really uh released
the information of the heart attack gun
and a lot of other horrible things that
the intelligence agencies were doing in
secret uh but we also have to understand
that this was uh Elon responding
directly to questions being asked to him
specifically if he's going to be
suicidal at any point in time in his
life and and this spurred on this
reaction which of course everyone's
talking about as we're still waiting for
the Twitter files 2.0 to be released
that we're hearing or in the hands of uh
Barry Weiss so there's still a lot more
there's some people saying that this was
a nothing Burger there's a lot of people
saying that this is the a huge a huge
reveal that I think is going to have
significant changes in our society but
it all depends I I guess where you stand
politically it's a Smoking Gun I mean
the Twitter files so one of the things
they're mentioning is that that the the
request from the DNC the specific links
were nudes of Hunter Biden Now Fair
Point uh I can understand why somebody
would be like yeah I don't want those up
but why is the DNC making those requests
and not you know say hunter Biden for
personal reasons so the first they have
to consider the Democratic National
Committee was trying to get these
private images from a private citizen
who was not running for office removed
so when the left comes out and says
Hunter Biden's not the president not
running he's not relevant okay well then
why is the DNC trying to well because
obviously it's relevant the second thing
is the images corroborate the laptop is
real
if someone came out and said look at
this email that's fake how do I know
that email's real because here's a
picture of Hunter Biden in a private you
know revealing circumstance that he took
himself that was along with it okay not
a guarantee the email's real but it does
lend some evidence to the fact so when
they start when the Democrats literally
are taking down images of of a third
party who's not running for office
that's bad but more importantly when it
came to the laptop in general the the
files reveal that they had no policy
justification for removing it argued
about how they had no policy
justification for removing the laptop
story did it anyway and then a big
mistake metai be made with all due
respect because I think that Matt does a
great job and I think he's fantastic
Jack pesobic posted the FEC the federal
election documents from yoel Roth of
Twitter saying the FBI contacted us said
there would be hacked materials related
to Hunter Biden then they just
arbitrarily removed that story BS the
FBI like Mark Zuckerberg said reached
out to them and said the story's coming
get rid of it what did uh taibi what
mistake did Tybee make did he not
include that taibis he didn't and he
said that I've seen no evidence of
government involvement in the censorship
of this and then later Jack busovic
posted an FEC document from fec.gov
where Joel Roth was like yes they
contacted me yes they said the
information that Hunter Biden was coming
and that and to be careful about it Mark
Zuckerberg said exact same thing yeah
and the New York Post released the story
today talking about the FBI's hack and
leak operation which they had weekly
meetings with a big Tech social media
companies and they came to them and they
said hey Hunter Biden is a target of a
hack and leak operation that's going
after him before the story even was
public so they knew they probably knew
that the New York Post was working on
this story they knew it was going to go
public so they preemptively spread this
information spread lies in order to
confuse and stop a narrative that would
make the uncoming political party look
uh bad that that right there is is is
very very Sinister nasty actions that
are absolutely playing totally unfair
when it comes to this political
landscape and I have to stress it's not
just the FBI according to this document
from fec.gov since he wrote since 2018
I've had regular meetings the office of
the Director of National Intelligence
the Department of Homeland Security the
FBI and Industry peers regarding
election security he goes on to mention
that these expectations of hack and leak
operations were discussed throughout
2022 I also learned these meetings that
there were rumors that a hack and leak
operation would involve Hunter Biden so
to clarify DHS FBI industry peers the
dni were in contact with Twitter
consistently for years and in 2020 said
negative information about Hunter Biden
is coming who's this FEC who's the I I
noticed okay as you can see right here
signed Joel Roth head of site Integrity
Twitter Inc December 17 2020. I I think
that the writings on the wall with
government collusion with big Tech I
mean I think it's obvious and it's
becoming more apparent and more legally
Justified if we're going to make these
claims with evidence like this but what
what when I'm reading the patterns of
humanity what it looks like right now is
this is a chance to step up each of us
because it's like whack you know the
whack-a-mole game someone steps up and
tries to change society they get whacked
and that's been happening since Kennedy
since I don't know I'm claiming that I
don't have I mean I've got a lot of
evidence that Kennedy was obviously
Kennedy was killed but I'm not saying
who did I don't know who did it I know
apparently anyway
the chance this is where we all have to
step up and take some of the the focus
onto ourselves because if we let Elon we
think he's some superhero he's just a
vulnerable guy so I want to be on you
know team Humanity here
yeah look I think that where this is
going to start to focus is on the um
private versus public element here
private versus government element
because what you hear is the argument is
no well this is a private Enterprise
they were you know it was a private
citizen at the time Joe Biden he was
just a candidate he wasn't involved with
government and look this is you know a
private company and that's the argument
that's being made but what's really
interesting is it was the DNC which once
again you can claim that is private but
then you have public government
officials as part of the DNC right so
you have what could hypothetically be
considered in more the business or the
corporate world piercing the corporate
veil right and by that I mean is is that
yes so you have all of this through this
shell company the DNC that's private but
then you have public influencers or
stakeholders that are on that private
committee or that private you know group
that are then influencing this through
so then did you pierce that veil in the
in the food world right as a franchisor
I am responsible by way of new laws for
the labor practices of a franchisee that
was a recent ruling right and that gets
into that kind of that corporate
public-private piece of this and so if
in the private business world I'm
responsible as a franchisor for what my
franchisee does even though I have
nothing to do with it by way of just
that connection well then government
should be held to the exact same
standard
there's a very interesting article by
Jonathan Turley that uh was released
also that was titled six degrees from
James Baker a familiar figure re-emerges
with the release of the Twitter files
that details how you know a lot of this
was was centered around from the very
beginning this whole Russian collusion
narrative this whole uh larger agenda
here from Central figures within the
federal government that were engineering
a lot of this and when we kind of look
at this we gotta we kind of got to ask
ourselves obviously there was some
incentive by big Tech social media
companies to try to make the Democrats
win since the Democrats are more
favorable towards uh big Tech monopolies
rather than of course Republicans that
were kind of threatening to put them in
check threatening in in not even a real
way but but kind of soft-handed way kind
of hinting that they that they might be
interested in doing something like the
Republicans always do and then they kind
of back off and scare just like
teenagers trying to go up to a girl uh
that's that's essentially what a lot of
the Republicans did here and I think
this is you know one reason why to
speculate uh what's really going on here
is it the Private Industry or is it the
the public industry who's really
responsible here to me it doesn't matter
they're all in bed together a lot of
these individuals are working together a
lot of these individuals know that they
need to depend on each other they have
blackmail on each other and to me this
is a no-brainer that they're codifying
the elections for their own personal
benefit and but to go along with the
private argument right let's Galvanize
that argument and say okay it's all
private then and anybody can do what
they want and that's the argument it's
done well then why why are people going
after Elon so much it's a private
company he can do whatever he wants so
you can't kind of Scream the sky is
falling on one side but then use the
same argument against or for whichever
side you're on
um and I think that that's something
that's just being ignored in all of this
when when when the two sides are
battling it out it was interesting to
see the White House response to all of
this they finally decided to release an
official statement saying that the
Twitter files were quote a distraction
in old news that are diverting attention
from Twitter's quote hate and
disinformation so very weaponized very
kind of Orwell unit terms used by the
White House in response to all this and
Elon Musk looks like he's not backing
down there's going to be more releases
in the future there's also a lot of
rumors that he's going to be starting a
medical experts panel that's going to be
questioning the government's logic when
it comes to health advice and he also
came out recently and talked about how
he thinks that the FTX Scandal is a lot
bigger than what people make it out to
be and he's claiming that it's it's it
could be nearly one billion dollars that
was given to Democrats via dark Channels
with untraceable money so there's a lot
of things happening behind the scenes
that we don't know about but it it
definitely is a very fascinating battle
with Elon Musk saying he's afraid for
his life essentially trying to say that
he's not going to be Epstein he's saying
that the the risk for assassination is
real
I want to uh talk about this next story
to the best of my abilities and explain
why I have a tweet
and y'all have been go lighten up the
chat about it I said there's a nine
millimeter bullet lodged in my kitchen
now I can't say I'm surprised this
happened after the wave of doxing and
threats made against us
I can't reveal too much of the details
about what happened but this morning I
got word that my house had been
um I don't know what the right word is
burglarized is the legal term but people
typically think burglary implies theft
of goods there was no theft there was uh
reportedly two men who broke in climbed
through a window
one of our staff members on site alert
yelled out
let me just say very carefully a shot
was fired the individuals were nearly
struck they fled they left behind a
wallet and an ID which is very very
strange nothing appears to have been
missing and we don't know what this was
about okay entirely possible that this
was a random occurrence considering
we've been swatted so many times
considering we have active threats and
the far left has been posting uh let's
just say posting an address that they
believe is my house it's not on the
internet excessively
the first thing we thought was seems
like it may be random or
um localized and then after going over
the scenario talking with some
individual security for instance we were
like okay actually it seems like this
might actually be political because the
things we would expect from a burglary a
typical burglary area didn't happen the
property in question is is large with
multiple buildings on it and without
giving too many details away we
ultimately concluded that your typical
robbery wouldn't occur in a situation
like this I don't know exactly what
happened
um you know we just know that it did
uh that's what's been reported by well
we have the police report that was filed
the police took evidence and um
the reason why I want to bring this up
is that I've been talking about I talked
about this last week
we've been swatted uh several times and
we've not reported it uh everybody knows
that we've been swatted over a dozen
times at the bomb squad here and
everything like that and we keep being
told by uh people don't say anything
don't let anybody know what's happening
and the first the first time I heard
that I'm like it's kind of odd like
shouldn't we let people know that there
are people trying to murder us because
then like I don't know it just feels
like if something happens no one will be
prepared for it we should be like hey
guys these threats are real they're
happening and what we kept being told
was if you say it it will it will keep
happening and I'm like okay you know
what I agree it's a tired narrative so
we actually stopped mentioning that
swattings were happening guess what they
still keep happening guess what after
all the the death threats and and
threats against us I don't blame Elon
Musk you know I I've I've I was thinking
about reaching out to him being like
dude there are people posting addresses
for me Matt Walsh and a variety of
people and they are spamming them and
mass like crazy there's got to be some
way of getting rid of this but I'm like
what do you really do how do you really
deal with this
so now my attitude is is basically this
the left came out and we'll talk about
the story in a second and said that a
Transformer substation was shot up by
far right Wingers trying to shut down a
drag performance
every single time something happens
jussie Smollett 2.0 they claim the far
right the far right last week one of our
guests said if you go to the average
person and ask them who's more likely to
commit political violence a left Winger
or a right winger they will tell you
outright a right-winger despite the fact
that it's substantially more likely to
come from the left just in every
capacity I know the ADL has their weird
rankings but they claim that black
nationalists are left-wing and white
nationalists are right-wing and none of
that makes sense
and I think that there's a reason for it
how often does Ben Shapiro talk about
the threats that he gets rarely if ever
how often does your typical antifa talk
about the threats they get they won't
shut up about anything they get a DM
where someone says you're fugly and
they'll post it and say I'm under attack
they're trying to kill me so what
happens The Narrative you start seeing
in mainstream conversation is the left
is constantly being threatened and the
right is fine when in reality this stuff
is happening to us so I don't know if
this incident in question was political
but I find it hard to believe it's a
coincidence has happened around the time
that people have been spamming you know
people have been posting on Twitter that
we shouldn't be allowed to live
comfortably but I don't know what you
guys think the story is a little
perplexing because it sounds like I'm
not gonna you know be careful yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not gonna you
know I I I I know the drill I've been
through this before it's this has been
you know our entire career this is
nothing new I mean except the more the
the levels of intensity keeps
um just keeps getting uh you know higher
and higher but I was going to say this
is uh this is either a case of the wet
Bandit from a home alone or just someone
messingly uh messing with with us so
um just deliberately trying to
intimidate and scare us so I I think you
know again who knows what's really going
on here I think a lot of the things are
done to confuse people it could be a
bunch of idiots
um you know poverty is increasing a lot
of people are poor a lot of people are
desperate but but the official story of
what happened doesn't really add up to
that doesn't really make sense and the
idiocy of it it doesn't really make
sense at all especially with the
identification card
um yeah that that right that way there's
like okay either they're the lowest IQ
idiots of all time the dumbest criminals
of all time or someone's deliberately
trying to you know send a message well
remember when the planes hit the World
Trade Center
um a passport fell out of the burning
explosion explosion and fell down to the
ground that's how they found the
terrorists that did it that's a good
point
it may just be that this guy who broke
in had a wallet with nothing but a
single ID in it and my understanding is
the ID wasn't even in it when they fled
so that means he he climbed in and just
said oh I better check my wallet for my
ID and took it out place it down looked
at it and then had to flee the building
how convenient that now we have a wall
an identification and someone to go
after how convenient I don't like this I
don't like talking about it publicly but
what I will talk about is the victim
mentality because I know what you mean
about people claiming oh they hurt me
they're violent towards me but you never
hear Ben you don't hear Ben Shapiro say
when he gets docs you don't hear Disney
say when they get doxed because
entertainment companies get docs that's
what happens that's why they have big
walls around their their studio
um but at some point
I don't like playing the victim card I
don't like being like he's I got hit
today everybody look how sad I am oh I
got hurt today everyone look at me look
at me but at some point I mean it's
worth being honest about what's
happening not complaining about it it's
just the nature of the entertainment
industry
there's one reason I tweeted about it
when I heard him right so I wake up in
the morning and phones are going nuts
because it happened at 7am like I wake
up and like I'm in bed getting up
getting ready and it's literally
happening I wasn't at this property in
question
and um I said look I've I've told people
please For the Love of All That is Holy
if you hate my guts if you don't want me
to be alive whatever do not come to my
properties you're allowed to hate me you
can hate hate me all you want but if you
come to these properties there is a
strong possibility you will lose your
life no one is going to sit back and be
like well despite all the death threats
um I'm gonna give this person benefit
out as they shatter the window and climb
through I don't know what they're doing
but you know let's just ask them
politely that's not what any of our
security guys are going to do no the
security guys you're lucky if if you're
uninjured when you leave those guys who
are probably hurt so that that's the
main reason I was like you know I talked
about it and said I think I should put
that out just so that like I can make
sure this is loud and very clear
you know I do not want anyone getting
hurt and if you come here so we have
people trying to troll we have stupid
games and there's a reason why
you know who knows some some morons
you know coming up I have no idea but uh
I I just you know I have to wonder about
with all of this going on the other
significant portion of the story is that
it's been a year since we uh the
swattings began and we've been swatted
on average more than once per month
sometimes twice
where's law enforcement I've I've tried
to reaching out to some the amount of
crimes that have been committed against
us in terms of violent and as well as
what I what I'd consider like white
collar crimes if we could talk about it
people would would crap their pants but
we can't because active investigation
self-law enforcement but for some reason
nothing's being done about it
I think I realized something a scary
thing Marjorie Taylor green was swatted
what six times
six she's a sitting member of Congress
you mean they can do nothing to protect
a city member of Congress
okay well that says everything right
there the courts and law enforcement are
incapable of actually maintaining social
cohesion at this point
the we hear all of these stories about
uh the summer of love the deaths from
the the 30 plus people dead from antifa
and there's zero accountability towards
any of it
sounds to me like
maybe it's not Civil War in the sense
that people uh expect as we often say
like two sides fighting it's just a
collapse of social cohesion the the FBI
the doj are working with big Tech to
benefit the Democrats they're not going
after the people protesting in front of
the justices homes they are go after
pro-life activists social cohesion is
shattered completely
the courts are unable to do anything the
crimes are getting worse I wonder if
they ever were able to do anything and
if it was always just like the the
Visage of strength and force like the
fear of threat of the cops there's so
there's a lot of like 30 cops and like
700 000 people they'll have like weird
you know ratios like that like one cop
to 700 humans No One Cop can't stop nine
guys like not realistically maybe that
that maybe that's it maybe they've never
been able to do it you know but I don't
know
yeah look it's it's pretty scary and I
think that you actually bringing it up
is smart in the sense of people
understanding that there is a threat on
the other side of this kind of like
fictitious wall that everybody wants to
cross to try and scare whether it's you
or somebody else and I think you can see
it in California right so I'm in
Huntington Beach which is Orange County
up in Los Angeles there was this huge
kind of rash of all these grabbing you
know Smash and grab into the jewelry
stores where they just they come in they
grab everything and there were certain
situations where people would fight back
well then they start to move into Orange
County now Orange County is notorious
for being very different political lead
in Los Angeles a little bit looser on
the concealed carry laws what happens
when they come in they hit Huntington
Beach they go into a jeweler which is
right down the street from us guy is
care the guy has a concealed carry pulls
his gun out shoots three of them there
was four different cars because they do
these in these big groups well you know
what I never heard of again after that a
smash and grab in Orange County yeah
very true but you hear about them in
Beverly Hills you hear about them on Bel
Air everything like that oh yeah they're
still happening all the time I mean
they're happening up in L.A like I'm I
mean it's just kind of an everyday thing
now yeah you you know people now
actually they have tourists that go to
La and they they're just sitting waiting
to see if they can videotape or Smash
and grab instead of going to no I'm just
kidding yeah you'll get lucky one day
there's enough to happen Jordan Peterson
talks about this a lot more eloquently
than I could ever can saying if you uh
are prepared for violence the likelihood
of violence coming your way is uh
reduced essentially saying if you learn
self-defense you you will learn how you
absolutely don't need it in many
instances you know a lot of the stuff
out in the streets is is a lot of the
times when it comes to conversation and
fights a lot of it is ego a lot of it is
just people not knowing when to walk
away but when someone comes into your
house I mean that's another level that's
another thing to to really kind of take
seriously uh you know people should
always have the right to to defend
themselves but also know exactly what
they're doing they should receive
training
um and they should take the situation
very seriously because you know as time
goes on I think it's only fair to say
that especially in in major city areas
people are going to become more poor a
lot of them are going to become more
desperate and a lot of the major cities
are going to become a lot more Lawless
and the only person you could really
depend on yourself for defending
yourself is you yeah no one else the the
[ __ ] people that want to hurt kill
violently don't care about them the
Constitution they're going to get a
weapon and do it you can't stop that the
constitution protects people from
Legally defending themselves the Second
Amendment particularly like the threat
of retaliation is what has protected the
United States for about a hundred
thousand years
um but like the reason why people aren't
dropping drone I mean there has been
attacks on You could argue on the United
States 911 being an instance of someone
attacking the United States uh
but it's the fact that we're all armed
and ready to just snap back with nuclear
weapons with you name it orbital strikes
people do not mess with that because
they don't want to get obliterated and
it's the same with menial criminals on
the street if they know you're packing
they're not going to touch you they're
going to look for someone that's been
legally muted and not able to have a
weapon or something like that or someone
that's elderly or vulnerable you know
it's disgusting but that's reality this
is what I can't understand about
California right I mean if you're if
you're one of these ultra wealthy
celebrities as stalkers living in the
Hills what do they just got to hire like
50 armed guards around their house all
the time like why wouldn't you want to
be armed I don't I never understood that
personally
maybe the rich people are allowed to be
armed is that it a lot of them a lot of
them are a lot of them just have massive
walls which uh you know aren't big
beautiful 30-foot walls yeah yeah he's
true big big beautiful beautiful as they
call for open borders I do like big
walls I've come to really appreciate a
large walled compound or walls or fences
and Gates around your house I like you'd
love South Africa man everybody's walled
in oh it's walls it's fences it's
everything is that because it's like
posts colonialism crime is pretty
serious there right yes crime in South
Africa is rather serious business and
can you have guns yes and uh you can get
guns relatively easily but uh yes
legally protected people can be armed in
South Africa
um I don't know for sure probably not
but everyone has private security anyway
so yeah isn't it like there's like
private police basically because they're
so companies are so big yeah what is
that like basically everyone has private
security because the police force
doesn't really work or in some cases the
police force works but they won't come
out or they're like oh it's too
dangerous or it'll be like oh we'll be
there but they'll be there in 40 minutes
and by that time you know things have
already elapsed it's not really it's
been your better interest to have
weapons and have firearms and be ready
to protect yourself at all costs because
uh you know the sa police force is not
going to be yeah they did the same thing
in Detroit I believe I believe there's a
full report of individuals just hiring
private uh security that was armed and
them doing a lot better job than police
officers that of course are giving
people tickets and generating revenue
for the state or shutting down small
businesses for daring to defy lockdowns
what um how do you guys handle
restaurant security and you don't have
to be specific if it's all under the you
know behind closed doors conversation
but what do you guys do yeah no that's
actually a great question
um because restaurants are targeted
pretty heavily especially given the the
cash nature of restaurants and then of
course you know the fact that there's so
many people that actually go into the
restaurants and the reason why I say
that's a risk now is because they
actually they're targeting places where
there are a lot of people with Handbags
and jewelry Etc and they're just robbing
everybody in the restaurant so uh you
know cameras look you know chefs with a
ton of knives and most of of them have
psychological disorders that's I
wouldn't want to cross that line but
you know what I think is kind of
happening is there's a distributed
denial of service in terms of crime
occurring crimes we see these videos of
people shoveling stuff into bags at
Walgreens or Target or whatever uh
rampant violent crime in New York
skyrocketing everywhere it's so much
crime happening at once yeah that not a
single one can actually be solved so you
know if crime is at a certain level the
police are able to prosecute and arrest
and stop some of it but once it goes
slightly above that level
you got 10 phone calls and they're all
saying I got to deal with this problem
the cops are like yeah we can I mean
first of all if the cop was going to
arrest that guy that guy that guy that
guy that guy that guy that guy they'd
have to go and testify to each of those
instances in court several times not not
always sometimes it's like open a check
case but not but it's just impossible
like you you were mentioning thirty
thousand forty thousand cops in New York
City to 13 million people in the Metro
2.5 million in Manhattan but it's
impossible to deal with and then and
then if you throw in even the slightest
sophistication to the crime itself well
now you're dealing with a whole nother
level we had a we had a team member who
was a scammer we didn't know it total
con artist and then it's ripping us off
for thousands and thousands of dollars I
believe the story and wasn't going to
prosecute it first and then we got uh
the police involved they were like oh
this is a they've done it before look at
their background this now I said let's
go after them then we want we got to
stop this dead in the tracks et cetera
et cetera and they're like oh we're not
gonna do anything about it right like
well you know how much Manpower that
takes and the case that we have to make
and keep as you said go back go back so
even if it's you know the slightest bit
of sophistication where it requires more
than 30 minutes or there's not a literal
Smoking Gun you're right and it's not
just like minor crimes it's not just
home invasions it's also murders it's
also uh people men forcing themselves on
women it's also assaults in the adult
nature there's there's horrible crimes
that go unpunished because the cops are
like well we just can't do anything or
some cops just don't feel any initiative
or or have no reason to actually stop or
try to prevent or trying trying to get
any justice at all there's no reason for
them I was talking to a lawyer about the
swattings and about Marjorie Taylor
green and I said what is the process for
dealing with federal crimes I said of
course you contact the U.S attorney in
the area where you know the crime is
being committed or whatever and I said
so we've got
14 or 15 swattings at this point bomb
squad shut up twice Studio has been
evacuated how do they have nothing and
not only that but we actually have a ton
of evidence we have a ton of
circumstantial evidence statements made
by potential suspects and you know other
stuff I I don't want to reveal too much
because I don't want to give it I don't
want anyone to realize exactly what we
have and they're just like oh yeah yeah
they look at it and they're like wow
that's that is that is compelling uh
FBI's underfunded understaffed and
uninterested and I'm like okay but they
can go after they can go to Roger
Stone's house at three in the morning or
whatever or they can they yeah they can
do this kind of stuff where they they
arrest uh some they raid the home of
some lady and was it FBI who rated the
home of some Lady in Alaska because I
thought she was at January 6th or
something yep yeah they can do stuff
like that they can go after 12 12 agents
and go after a pole rope at a garage oh
yeah I remember that one but we can't be
like here is a stack of evidence from a
private security company we think we
know who's doing it and they're like
sorry in times of like uh of a golden
age of where we were in like a time of
insane Prosperity from 1970 tonight to
now you know in the United States where
you could call the police and they'd
come to your house and be like what's
wrong can I help you like uh if Society
starts to break down in any fashion
defer to the Constitution you have the
First Amendment and the Second Amendment
to back you up you have the right to
defend yourself in your property in this
country I want to jump to this next
story but but real quick I just want to
say
um uh as of 8 P.M news Brook that Kirsty
alley has passed away oh man yeah a
tweet on Kirstie Alley's uh page says
sad to inform that our Fierce loving
mother has passed away after Battle of
cancer so rest in peace someone someone
super chatted and I was kind of like
what you know because I have to just
joke and then I pulled it up yeah so
rest in peace sad to hear yeah I was
gonna say that I loved look who's
talking as a movie but it's like you
know what Christy God bless you my man
woman love you your family everybody out
there the alleys whatever your last
names are love you guys sorry to hear
but beautiful human well life is short
you got to cherish every moment you have
and you got to protect it too that's
right let's jump to the story from
timcast.com drag show protester
questioned by police after intentional
vandalism Cuts power to 40 000 North
Carolina residents police have yet to
name a suspect or announce a potential
motive so the first story is shootings
at Power substation cause North Carolina
outages holy crap I mean that's that's
really what they're saying two power
substations in North Carolina were
damaged by gunfire and was being
investigated as a criminal act causing
damage that could take days to repair
leaving tens of thousands of people
without electricity
a protester who was protesting the drag
events posted on Facebook the power is
out in Moore County and I know why Emily
Grace Rainier on Facebook on our
Facebook page according to the Daily
Beast around the same time she posted a
photo of the Sunrise Theater the venue
holding the sold out drag shows in the
caption God will not be mocked so police
apparently uh met with this woman she
said that she's sorry for wasting their
time and what she meant to say was that
God works in mysterious ways the
implication was more so that the power
went out because the Lord was angry not
that they had any information that right
Wingers were attacking a power
substation which sounds really stupid as
it is a bunch of conservatives being
like I know to turn off the power in a
single location shut down the entire
grid makes no sense but what does matter
is that many of these and uh many
leftist individuals are outright
asserting it is true or at the very
least they're pushing the idea without
Merit the police have even said it's not
the case they're posting on Twitter the
escalation is is happening I'm not
saying all this uh I mentioned earlier
in my other show to be a black Bell I'm
just saying this is happening and I
often point out
when we were seeing these stories four
years ago where the left would accuse a
right winger of doing something I'm like
you realize it doesn't matter if it's
true they believe it anyway even when
you can prove it Covington kids Russia
gate hands up don't shoot they don't
care
so what happens in a situation like this
where not only now do we have escalation
not only now do we have you know Elon
Musk saying he's he's afraid he's going
to die you have the far left outright
saying right Wingers are shooting up
substations in Acts of Terror
one thing I try to do is to when I it
when if and when I come into contact
with people that believe stuff like that
I try to have the same amount of
Amazement when they find out they're
wrong to to go to kind of empathize with
their amazement as they're realizing oh
it wasn't targeted and then I'm like
okay I I get it now and I feel what
you're feeling as opposed to be like you
idiot of course it wasn't targeted just
be there with them while they realize
that they were not seeing the truth at
the time that's what that's one you know
but they're jumping to conclusions it's
not a truth it's automatically
everything is is right wing it's it's
them it's the political opponents that
that kind of deranged lunacy is is
dangerous it's not you know an
individual who's critically thinking or
assessing information that's actually
you know the responsible adult thing to
do here is wait until we have evidence
now we're trying to weaponize everything
it could be a lunatic it could be a
crazy person it could not even be
politically motivated it could be just
some guy or some kid be like hey look at
what I could do you know just some
deranged individual who knows I got to
be honest it sounds more likely to be
climate change activists and and antifa
than a right winger who was upset with
one drag event you've got you've got
people like Greta tunberg how dare you
you know it's like they want to shut the
power off yeah they want to get rid of
oil they want to get rid of energy they
want to literally create human Calamity
style events that would devastate
Humanity kill millions of people all
because they don't like oil well let me
throw out a hypothetical what if in
protest to all these drag events the
right wing actually started to throw
paint on classic paintings that were
worth millions of dollars how would that
be covered
yeah I don't I don't think anyone's
happy about that to be honest like you
know they're getting mocked by everybody
the people doing that over the climate
change stuff the the guy who's funding a
ton of it is a massive well-known
Hollywood producer he's put like three
to four million dollars into the
organization that is actually doing this
there's it's pretty funny because and I
bring that up because of the hypocrisy
of somebody who celebrates art as this
big Hollywood producer he he learned how
to weaponize autism and mental illness
very effectively and these these
children you know clearly show us that
there is a mental health crisis clearly
believe they have been so scared that
the world is ending because we have
politicians like AOC that go on the
bully pulpit and like the world's going
to end in eight years again not even
quantifying real data not even going
after anything legitimate but just
making things up out of thin air just to
radicalize just to scare people and then
we have these effects of of it which
would bring on more pain and suffering
to humanity than we could even imagine
which is crazy
but it's interesting to see who finances
a lot of this stuff it's interesting to
see the result of this it's interesting
to see the news coverage of this because
uh you know they've been trying to push
through a lot of these lockdowns a lot
of these restrictions they're going to
be testing some of them out in the
United Kingdom for many years now they
couldn't they couldn't never do it but
then you know covet happened and now
covet is surely looking like it's going
away so they need something else to of
course bring on the trauma-based mind
control I want you guys to imagine
something
John Brown's raid on the Harpers Ferry
Armory he made one critical error he let
a train leave
when John Brown and his crew rated the
army they basically took it they had it
information could not travel
but a train was passing through and they
knew what was going on but he let them
go the train I think made its way to
Baltimore I could be wrong with the
details but it basically got out
informed the authorities who then
quickly mustered their forces and then
headed to the Harper's Harpers Ferry to
stop this basically John Brown was
trying to cause like a slave Uprising or
something that effect and I'm just
thinking about this today's day and age
information is instant something happens
the Tweet goes out but I'm just thinking
about what it must have been like to say
be on that train knowing you were the
only person carrying the message of this
attack and that if you don't make it in
five hours time or however long it took
two or three hours to the city to inform
law enforcement they would take this
city they would have it and that would
be the end of it it's a crazy it's a
crazy concept is this a metaphor for
Twitter files 2.0 no it's just it's just
understand how vastly different things
have become and how that's having an
impact on politics yeah used to be that
the you would try and prevent the truth
from getting out governments would spend
time subverting and putting people in
prison and things like that now it's
impossible the truth now the idea is to
put out so much fake information that
the truth Blends in and you can't tell
what's what and and this this isn't just
limited to politics right because I'm
obviously going to bring a culinary
angle to this but let me just it comes
to food too so many headlines people
read about food are wrong and then it
affects their dining choices for 10 to
20 years I've actually gone to the
extreme of saying that because of the
government headlines about eating
Seafood being a bad thing because of all
this hypothetical Mercury and pcbs which
actually nobody's ever died of mercury
poisoning we eat less Seafood instead we
eat more meat and chicken which is high
in omega-6 fatty acids which is the seed
oil issue which is your inflammation and
therefore people are dying at a younger
age because of that it happens in food
it happens in every single industry and
the people who perpetuate these lies
it's the mainstream media because yes
you're always going to have people on
the right or the left who are going to
go out there and tweet obviously
outrageous headlines but when it gets
picked up by the media and then
basically adds credibility to it and
then they go on with that lie well
that's when this social cohesion the
fabric starts to rip at the seams and
then we all believe the liar many of us
do so you're saying I should just eat
nothing but raw salmon you should eat as
much Seafood as you can six of the eight
leading causes of death in the United
States can be alleviated through the
healthy consumption of omega-3 fatty
acids mainly found in Seafood is there
any problem to overdoing scallops
scallops well you might be a little bit
higher in cholesterol but then just cut
back on something else see there's a
reason I love oysters and there's so
much propaganda against them oysters
oysters are vegan
well think about it they actually have a
negative effect on the environment
because they're filter feeders so they
clean the environment so they have a
negative effect right I mean in a good
way and then there's there's no
vertebrae they're not sentient in any
capacity they're basically vegetables
don't insult them this this way stop it
which is why it's so they're delicious
we should be basically eating more
oysters the poor oysters
filter feeding yeah but I mean you can
clean entire estuaries just with oysters
alone if you took 100 oysters and put it
in a big fish tank full of dirty water
and then watch over the next day or so
that water will be clean and all of the
dirt you think well then it must be
going into the protein and the food that
I eat no it doesn't it actually goes
into the shell which is then calcified
and then you can use that shell ground
up as fertilizer or nutrients in soil
when you do some sort of organic farming
it's completely closed loop there's so
many solutions to the problems they say
that are out there that nobody wants to
consider there's a lot of conflicting
data when it comes to high cholesterol
we should talk about that in just a
little bit but but if we could just stay
on topic here just a little bit you made
a very no no no no no no you made a very
good point saying you know people hear
one thing and people jump to conclusions
without actually doing the the work to
you know towards understanding something
fully especially when it comes to diet I
think that's one of the most
misunderstood things when it comes to
our Mainline Society especially with the
Obesity crisis that we're all dealing
with right now and how people are
getting absolutely wrecked and destroyed
because of the disinformation and
because of the poison that's out there I
also think there's a lot of you know
just like we should be careful about
what we put into our bodies we should be
careful about what we put into our minds
and I think a lot of these people have
been so traumatized by the echo Chambers
by the by the what's the circles called
not family friendly Circles of of
thought that that happen on social media
that they've been so radicalized that
automatically something bad happens
they're going to point to their
political opposition as their main
reasonable force behind everything ill
and wrong in this world just like the
club Q shooting again that story went
away very quickly why isn't anyone
talking about it anymore when there was
a certain agenda behind it now that the
agenda has been questioned somewhat
automatically the stories just dropped
by the corporate media when they were
talking about this thing like it was the
end of the world come on there's a lot
of things to to really consider here and
especially question let me let me let me
let me bring these stories together
because we we have a story here this is
from timcast.com police raid Virginia
restaurant that defied covet orders
owner says State officials tried to
strip him and his guests of their
constitutional rights the long story
short in Fredericksburg there is Gourmet
gormelts I'm sorry gormelts is the name
of the place right and it's a business
that refused to shut down during the the
lockdowns the masks and all that stuff
so they are trying to take away the
liquor license they say police officers
entered a Fredericksburg Virginia
restaurant and executed award to
confiscate alcohol and Records
pertaining to the sale of alcohol after
the state's Alcoholic Beverage Control
Authority ABC revoked the restaurants
liquor licenses following the owner's
refusal to follow mandates issued during
the covid pandemic the restaurant's
owner Matt Strickland had his alcohol
license suspended for 90 days in
September after they ruled he willfully
and knowingly ignored mandates
so I wake up and I watch this video
where these cops are going in and
they're and they're they're basically
shutting him down serving this warrant I
think he got like a 90-day uh suspension
and uh my first edit I got two things to
say on this and then we'll expand
because you've certainly you know been
dealing with this stuff one
you should watch this video and you
should share the video and if you live
in Fredericksburg you should tell
everybody you know these cops are not
welcome in your business if they want to
destroy a man's life because of
unconstitutional edict they don't
deserve a hot dog from your store they
don't deserve a new sweater they don't
deserve a cheeseburger the it is p is a
non-violent Civil Disobedience that
solve this problem let these officers
know you are shunned look anti-full I
say this stuff but they don't run
businesses they don't have jobs some of
them do I get it but the cops aren't
worried about that I'll tell you what
they are worried about when the the you
have the back the blue people the Maga
people the last line of people actually
defending the police and then the cops
want to pull something like this simply
say officer thank you for your service
now get out of my store I will not serve
you and then see how long that negative
cops being like look I'm not shutting
this business down I'll never be able to
show my face in this town again it used
to be that way people used to fear that
now if I if I do that mayor they'll
never show my face no now they don't
care so this guy films them good the
second thing I'm going to say is Luke on
Saturday do you want to go down to
Fredericksburg let's do it let's do it
let's support this business
and let's support the people who are
doing the good things and and and when
they're punished unjustly we should try
to do everything we can to help out
during those situations yeah I imagine
what what we could what can we do
peaceful organizing just to to highlight
this stuff
and I think highlights the first thing
and I think you know maybe I'll go down
and take a tour of Fredericksburg see
what's see what's going on maybe uh you
know we can reach out to this guy Matt
see what's up and ask him about what
happened and then get the full details
and maybe keep shining a light on this
stuff you guys should see the video and
if you haven't seen it you should watch
it as we're talking right now so you
understand what's happening I mean you
could see the shame on some of these
cops faces
we're not here to discuss whether or not
you're not here to discuss whether or
not the unconscious you're just here to
do your job right
[Music]
now
and you're going to enforce that
regardless right yeah
so you're part of the problem man I want
you to know that you're part of the
problem you're part of the problem
you're part of the problem
you're part of the problem everybody in
here every one of you man what's going
on in this country right now the reason
that we're in the situation we're in as
the United States of America you're part
of the problem sir
so you can't complain about what the
president is doing you can't complain
about the state that the country is in
right now you can't you can't complain
about how screwed up it is you're part
of the problem sir you're just doing
your job
so many people were just doing their job
for Hitler back in Germany
you as well sir that goes that goes for
you as well that goes for you as well
that goes for all of you
that goes for all of you man there's no
excuse there's zero excuse
just doing my job
that's not an excuse anymore man it's
not an excuse and you know what you know
why these cops don't care because they
know literally nothing will happen they
or I should say they think and um maybe
the simple the simple reality is just
say
first of all I want to be careful here I
want to make sure I stress this point
the Covington cans a video comes out
they accuse the kids of wrongdoing we
don't know for sure so we have the
general story here this has been an
ongoing thing and the general idea they
shut this guy down over refusing to
abide by the unconstitutional mandates
now the cops years later when the
mandates aren't in place anymore are
coming after him and causing damage to
his life
I want to make sure we're careful
because I'll say this make sure you look
into this don't be a knee-jerk
reactionary like the left was the
Covenant kids but assuming all the
reporting we have is true then you
should simply say to these officers uh
you're not welcome in my place of
business I don't want you coming around
my family I don't want you in my church
you are evil people it's the banality of
evil but uh uh Chef gruel I mean you
defied or I should say you spoke out
against so and what are your thoughts
seeing this story well I you know and I
think that's thank you for kind of
clarifying um because you're right you
don't know the back story here but just
looking at that video in and of itself I
can only imagine that it's nothing too
serious because number one if this guy
was doing anything that was criminal
he'd be arrested immediately if he was
doing something that was a violative of
ending Health standards he would be shut
down immediately gas would be cut from
his stores there would be messaging out
there so assuming that this is the
limitations on this you know two years
previous I mean that's just absurd and
the absurdity in general of a lot of
these mandated as I've talked about for
the past two years and have been
punished for doing so it people
understand it now right so you kind of
have this reverse process where now the
government which is typically behind the
times they are so far behind the times
that you have all people of both parties
looking at the absurdity of what went
down during covid in many cases not all
cases that making the case that this
just shouldn't be happening is a much
easier case to make but yet it's still
happening I cannot I mean two years
later that is absolutely nuts and you
had mentioned about 10 minutes ago you
said you know it was coveted and now
it's the next thing I don't think it's
the next thing I think we're in act
number 417 on covet and I think the
drama or the tragedy is going to
continue forward and they're going to
keep writing sequels to it with covid
being kind of the the main hero here
well they're going to try to milk this
cow as much as they can uh but we have
to understand with this particular case
looking into it there was a long series
of court cases okay and there there was
a ruling that came down which now
allowed the government to come in and
seize their records and to seize their
liquor license so this is what happened
here and we have to understand the
lunacy that people had to go through
within the last few years how absolutely
insane how absolutely evil it was in
California there was businesses that
that were padlocked there was
restaurants that were shut down there
was there was businesses that had
electricity cut by the city because they
dared to defy their arbitrary lockdown
orders meanwhile Walmart was allowed to
be open Costco was allowed to be open
all these big box stores with
connections to politicians they were
able to to run their businesses police
officers came on Grandma's door knocked
it down because she dared to keep her
business open even when she had an
online business the stories that
happened here in the United States
should terrify people because it
highlights the story of or of order
followers doing what they're told
committing human rights violations
against people of this country
real quick sorry just uh uh Matt
Strickland I see an individual became a
member of the channel right now and it
looks it may be the Matt Strickland
who's in this story so uh Matt if you
are listening I just followed you on
Twitter shoot me a DM if you want to say
anything right now about the subject
matter and we'd love to meet up maybe
this weekend talk about what's going on
but you were saying nice I love that um
and that's that's the beauty of
communication right there if that's the
case I was going to say that you know
some of these some of these stories
truly underscore the indifference that
government has for people you say human
the human rights issues I mean so if you
look in California they shut down
outdoor dining in the December of 2020
okay 75 degrees and sunny in Southern
California they shut door shut down
outdoor dining and then this was
concurrent with the state of California
saying oh and by the way you can't get
any unemployment funds until January
February because we've misappropriated
80 billion dollars in unemployment funds
so you shut down outdoor dining this is
the truth of what happened all these
people got fired like 80 of the
restaurant industry and SoCal got fired
oh and by the way it's going into the
holidays and Christmas and you have no
money because the unemployment funds
aren't available you had people just
left on the streets which is why we
started the fun to raise money we were
driving around the Night Before
Christmas handing out 500 checks and
giving people their rent money because
we had the raise the funds as
individuals because the government
wasn't going to do anything to help
these people meanwhile what happened
what was the result of these policies
the rich became richer than they ever
have before it was the it was the policy
that committed the largest transfer of
wealth from some of the poorest some of
the most people some of the few people
left in the middle class to the richest
billionaires that of course were able to
keep their online businesses open they
were able to do things that violated
health and cold protocols but but that
didn't matter it was essentially a
deliberate action I believe a lot of
this was actually done on purpose to
shut people down to to make sure that
they will won't have any wealth with
their families yeah it seems like it's
like trying to trying to get back at
someone you don't like because they made
you angry but the reality in reality uh
law enforcement is there's an ethical
quality to it like if jaywalking is
illegal fine if you're out in the middle
of the street because there's a little
baby laying there and you get you're
jaywalking to get that baby off the road
you're not going to get arrested you may
have jaywalked they're not going to find
you for that one because you did the
right thing in violation of the law
sometimes people see the forest through
the trees and just because there's a
top-down Creed doesn't mean that you
have to fall in line
uh sort of go after people that stayed
open during what they want to call a
pandemic in a time that how many people
like how much death did keeping that
restaurant create open create let's find
that out because if so if they're if
they if they murdered people with Keith
staying open put them in prison but if
they didn't what the hell is going on
Sweden has uh uh there's a there's a
tweet I put out a while ago someone
posted the data Sweden's all-cause
mortality or whatever it's called is
like lower than most of Europe and they
had no lockdowns or they had very very
limited restrictions so we're looking at
this data you can make an argument for
Sweden's weather they're they're further
north smaller population maybe more
spread out but on the surface you look
at the data and we don't see any strong
I mean look at Florida yeah I mean
Florida didn't lock down
well Donald Trump was telling Sweden to
lock down was saying Sweden's was going
to have a mashed casualty event this was
the the president of the United States
saying this and he was absolutely wrong
on on a lot of these things as his
administration started the two weeks to
slow the spread nonsense which which
again was absolutely ridiculous as the
government their only plan was to give
you a two thousand dollar check which
they couldn't even give you out in the
correct way they couldn't even get that
right uh but but what did that what did
that do that that only indebted this
country that only made people more
reliant on government and it gave them
not even a Band-Aid it gave him it was
like someone was on fire and the
government spat on you that's that's
exactly what I could kind of quantify to
the government giving you a two thousand
dollar check and some of the people were
really happy they were like yeah this is
it wasn't that money is going to have to
be accounted for paid for in some kind
of way what we saw with these lockdowns
what with these restrictions was
essentially the elites playing with
everyone saying let's see how far we
could push the this let's see how we
could how much we could torture them
let's see how much we could get away
with when it comes to stealing
everything from them including their own
businesses and seeing that was was cruel
and it was evil I want you guys to
remember
when they published videos of a
restaurant and I think it was Leesburg
going outside and grabbing cicadas Off
the Wall bringing them inside cooking
them and serving them to people this was
very illegal it was a food truck no no
it was a brick and mortar place and then
they got told they got shut down like
you can't sell these cicada tacos
anymore because you can't just take bugs
off the street and then cook them and
feed them to people that's what they had
people doing remember all of these news
stories eat the bugs eat the bugs yeah
that was actually celebrated as being
very uh avant-garde did you did you cook
any bugs no we don't well first of all I
think that the idea of cooking cicadas
is disgusting they're a chef and they're
they're also a derivative of shrimp so
if you have a shellfish allergy and
you're out there cooking cicadas to try
and be cute you're gonna die if you eat
a cicada Taco number one number two we
don't know where these cicadas have been
and if you look at their life cycle
actually they're full of toxins but
that's okay go ahead and eat the cicadas
oh let me just say also this this clear
statement shutting down outdoor dining
in Southern California killed people yes
because when and because of the fact
that people weren't going out and
sitting in an outdoor area to go out to
eat with their friends and family
everybody needs to go out they need that
social time what they did was they had
private House parties in small enclosed
areas instead elderly people Etc and
they got covered and they died eating
outside in 75 degree weather we knew
scientifically because we all saw the
headlines that the protests Outdoors
were totally safe right remember that
totally safe but we shut down outdoor
dining people died as a result of that I
do not understand the outdoor dining
shutdown well why why did they do it
they said that well the answer was they
said that the image that it gives to
people out celebrating and dining
Outdoors is that it's okay to be outside
during covet so you see how this is all
about the image the picture the
symbolism and I will give credit to the
Orange County uh sheriff's department
and all the police force in Orange
County we did remain open outdoors and
we did we continued to serve outside
um we got a ton of support our sales
were tripled and the the police force
said you're good to go we're not going
to enforce any of these rules so there
are local jurisdictions where there are
there are officers there standing up and
saying look we're not going to stand
behind these absurd regulations or
mandates
um and uh you know those are the places
you got to seek out and celebrate it was
arbitrary it was it was made up real
quick Matt just hit me up and he said
that he guarantees one thousand percent
the only reason they came after him was
because he did not follow the coveted
mandates and you know he he'd like to
come join us and talk about it more
that'd be fantastic and uh thanks for
hitting me up brother uh I'm sick of
seeing this stuff I'm sick of seeing all
these stories where you know we want to
come out and be like the defund the
police like well not Luke anyway but the
defund the police stuff goes too far
there there's a role for police the
average person who's not an anarchist or
or hardcore libertarian probably likes
the police but we cannot tolerate the
worst accesses of it now I know Luke's
solution is typically like no it's all
badges the police are ineffective they
have no incentive to actually provide
you a service they have no incentive at
all and and majority of crimes go
unsolved especially when it comes to to
to to rape so especially when it comes
to homicides especially when it comes to
very serious situations a lot of the
times you're left on your own so why not
just officially be on your own and be
prepared to defend yourself the
incentive really for a police officer is
to protect its Community his or her
community because if your neighbors are
getting so is this what these guys are
doing
um
do you feel protected when when you're
pulled over by a police officer on a
motorcycle that's writing you a ticket
for not wearing a seat belt
do you feel protected if I don't have a
seatbelt if I'm speeding and I get
pulled over I thank the cop because I'm
I'm endangering the community it looks
right sorry no dude I mean they're on a
motorcycle
thank you officer I was like oh come on
I pointed I was like come on and he went
get like like I'm gonna throw you in
jail if you do not it's not for your
safety it's it's for them to generate
Revenue people speeding are just out
there to kill I don't think people
should well hold on hold on someone's
speeding like I don't know 20 15 20
miles over I understand but Luke's got a
good point let's break that down like
you can't you have to wear a seat belt
in your car but the cop on a motorcycle
is literally just sitting on this thing
going 60 miles an hour you know what I
mean it is silly it's not for your
safety well I think it is they pull you
over they'll be like yo put your
seatbelt on because if someone hits you
you're gonna get killed they don't want
to clean up a bloody blood but there's
better ways of incentivizing those kind
of policies like he's on a motorcycle
right yes he has to weave through
traffic no but like he has to speed up
go faster than you are on a motorcycle
and and you know it's to get through
cars but isn't it like one in like 20 20
to 25 of people will suffer some kind of
accident on a motorcycle oh dude my Dad
ran himself over with a motorcycle one
time is he like he just flipped over the
front and then it went over him people
should be allowed to motorcycle I I got
a motorcycle they're great fun but there
is something that's inherently silly
about a motorcycle cop giving a ticket
for not wearing a seat belt like you are
safer without the seat belt in the car
than they are just on the motorcycle
following all the regulations yeah and
this is what a lot of the lockdowns were
all about it's all about protecting it
wasn't about protecting anyone it was
literally Dr fauci and other health
officials who weren't healthy a lot of
them were obese a lot of them were
disgusting a lot of them were just
absolutely unhealthy beasts sitting
there eating their donuts telling you
hey you know we'll give you free donuts
if you if you do this but you gotta also
jump through our Hoops that we're going
to literally make up the the documents
came out from the fauci emails and a lot
of these rules they're like hey where
did you think of these these six feet
where did you think of these Plexiglas
where's the science and logic behind it
and they were like oh there's none
there's is absolutely none of that it's
me just making things up as I go along
and the latest scientific data is
highlighting how a lot of these
protocols a lot of these things actually
made the situation that much worse and
more people got sick as a result of it
right let me let me tell you guys a
story
I told this before we I was in uh
Frederick Frederick whoever found in
Maryland and uh this was during lockdown
it was during mask mandates and all that
stuff and I went to get sushi and uh
I was with my girlfriend we walked into
the sushi restaurant we were standing
probably about five or ten feet from it
from a two-person table and we walked in
and I was like two and then they looked
at me and said you need to wear a mask
and then I looked around at everyone
everyone aside from the staff no masks
yeah and I was like um excuse me like
nobody's wearing masks and like well
they're eating and I was like oh yes I'd
like to eat as well and I said no but
put a mask on and I said well are you
serious like but they're not wearing
masks right now like I'll just sit down
is that okay and they're like no put the
mask on yeah and then I said you want me
to wear a mask for 10 seconds are you
serious and they all go everyone turns
it goes yes and I was like I'm leaving
like what is wrong with their brains
dude there was 50 people sitting around
with no masks on you know what I thought
you know I was in Frederick recently I'm
walking around I got a coffee and I
thought I made a mistake that day you
know what I should have done I should
have been like oh I'm sorry I should
have taking the mask and just gone like
this and just pulled it and held it
right in front of my face floating about
an inch away
and then just you know just just okay
I'll sit down and you want me to sit
down I'll sit down and go okay
I should have grabbed a napkin or
something at that point just cover your
mouth with just put it put your hand
over your face
yeah it's gonna do the same thing your
hand in the napkin is going to do the
same thing that a cloth mask would do I
thought about that when I was there and
I said you know when you go to West
Virginia they they did the Statewide had
mask mandates for stuff but like nobody
was really following it it was kind of
funny and so I just avoided any place in
West Virginia that actually had a sign
asking for Mass I was like this is
stupid what did your restaurants do if
you don't mind me asking and did you
guys have to comply with the Plexiglas
that went up in price very uh
significantly during this whole uh
shenanigan nonsense uh theater that we
had to go through I've got a warehouse
full of plexiglass right now I mean it's
like their Plexiglas was in such demand
I ended up having to meet some guy
behind a 7-Eleven at 2 30 in the morning
he bought it out of the back of a
Cadillac I mean it was like no I'm
kidding but plexiglass was it was so
hard to get it was virtually impossible
and we we left it up to the consumer and
we had people leave because they were
like they're not wearing masks but we
just let people decide what they wanted
to do but now that we're talking about
masks let me throw couple facts out
there three million masks are discarded
worldwide every single minute masks are
made of polypropylene all of those masks
all of them end up in the ocean guess
what polypropylene breaks down into
microplastics so in California okay I
have to now they are mandating masks
again in Los Angeles so I have to wear a
mask recently yeah yeah wow yeah they
reinstated The Mask so they're mandated
indoors all right that mask is going to
end up in the ocean it's going to be
microplastic going to end up in our
entire food system and it's going to
kill sea life now alternatively I if I
ask for a straw and a straw is given to
me both me and the person who gave it to
me get a fine if it happens twice it's
criminalized and you can go to jail for
it wow so you can't get the straw
because you got to save sea life but you
have to wear the mask to kill sea life
call me fornia I I have maybe this is a
hot take but I think that kovid
particularly is spreading and has been
spreading through the food supply not
through the air or maybe a spread it has
been spreading through the air as well
ice cream Theory
now from a Daily Mail as of December 3rd
broccoli and raspberries could give you
coven Health experts warn after learning
the virus can live on popular foods for
as long as a week I think that's I think
that's a little bit of a fear-mongering
protected on Peppers ham bread crust and
cheese for several days hold on just
pull up the story Ian's not wrong
broccoli Road on top of ice cream
the title is suggestive saying it could
not that it would it's been found it's
detected covet on Pepper's ham bread
crust and cheese
uh I mean absolutely the writing is on
the wall uh from from Newsweek covid-19
has now been found in ice cream uh this
is from you thought you got January
I think that it's lives in on food but
but they don't want to cause panic but
the thing is that that could be
scientifically true but we know that
covet is a respiratory so you have to
breathe it in if it lives on the food
it's an active culture but if you
swallow it then it's killed in your body
I think it lives on pineapple pizza I
mean you could smell the food so it's
like no one should ever order a
pineapple pizza exactly if you smell
because it has it on it very important
well if I could ask you you just talked
a little bit about the regulations in
California I couldn't imagine I I think
it would be my worst nightmare in my
life to open up a business with
California what what was it like
operating business there what are some
of the more insane regulations that you
have to go through that the people don't
know about well keep in mind too and
it's different in different parts of
California because everybody's like why
are you still living there well number
one because somebody's got to be
fighting in enemy territory and number
two there are certain areas where
there's reason and there's logic and
rationale Orange County being one of
them Los Angeles is incredibly difficult
when it comes to opening a business but
I'll tell this one story right so as I
had mentioned I started as a food truck
in 2011 and then grew the Enterprise I
had no money to start the first brick
and mortar I bought this Old Bagel Shop
it was a hole in the wall but it was a
turnkey situation the landlord was going
to take a chance on me and I think we
ended up raising like seventy thousand
dollars to open this and I had no money
after that not even a penny right when
we're about to open we do the kind of
final walk through with health and they
go where's your grease Interceptor the
underground one right I said oh it's
well we're grandfathered in because I
bought the lease it's an above ground
one they said yeah but that kind of
Grandfather piece is going to go away in
a couple years so just put the
underground one and I'm like look I
can't that's 20 25 000 they're like yeah
we don't care you got to do it so I'm
about to open so I have to take out a
high interest loan that I paid off like
14 years later at you know 39 interest
compounded every minute but the point is
twenty five thousand dollars the day
before my business is supposed to open
when there wasn't even a specific
regulation it was more just well it's
going to have to happen even though we
were told everything was going to be
okay that story kind of represents
California were they expecting a bribe
because it seems like a lot of mafioso
like people run a lot of these
regulations and they kind of expect some
money underneath the table just to not
Implement whatever made up nonsense they
want to implement that's more jersey
style Jersey is is is and I'm from
Jersey so um I know that uh in
California it's just an aptitude in
California it's the it's you're feeding
the bureaucracy and the bureaucracy
feeds the bureaucracy it's kind of like
a um you know a beast that eats itself
do you just love it there is that why
you're still there
um it is beautiful place um my wife was
was born and raised there and my kids
love it so you know I uh where are you
not you're in a not Long Beach near Long
Beach Huntington Beach it's such an
amazing area I mean it's gorgeous it is
Manhattan Beach Long Beach Venice up and
down the boardwalk you can ride your
bike I highly recommend everybody get a
chance to visit at some point in their
life it's so amazing but
why do you hate pineapple pizza
it's too wet so it drizzles on the pizza
I would do like a pineapple salsa with
jalapenos to finish the pizza but a
roast but roasted in sweet and sticky
pineapple releases way too much moisture
and then it it kills the dough if it
sits there too what if the pineapples
diced up super fine well in the in the
form of like a salsa that hasn't been
cooked because then it won't release all
that moisture what about dehydrated
pineapple too much work no I actually I
like that this could be the compromise
that people have been asking for I you
know it's funny I did I said I would
never eat pineapple pizza
um and I forget what I what it was about
and then Newsmax reached out to me and
said well you said you wouldn't if x
happens so we want to do a live shot of
you eating pineapple pizza on TV so we
so we actually did it that was the only
one and well the second time and last
time I'll eat pineapple pizza do you do
you use seed oils uh I I try not to
although seed oils are hidden in a lot
of different yeah different places
they're everywhere that's where I go
back to the omega-6s so seed oils are
bad because you have this this
balance of omega-6 fatty acids that
leads to inflammation and hypertension
and a lot of other issues so if you
actually eat more Seafood you can
theoretically balance out that that
inflammation and have a couple seed oils
sorry like what about all the gluten
stuff right you know a lot of people
don't want to eat it I've actually you
know so I cut out sugars about a year uh
it's been like a year now it's crazy I
can't believe how long it's been yeah
and I lost a lot of weight but I cut out
rice too and I've been adding uh so I
went like way down to like no carbs then
I then I sort of tried things next I
remember uh like Michaela Peterson and
Jordan Peterson we're talking about
nothing but meat and they said well the
very least an Elimination Diet you get
rid of everything and then slowly try
things and see which one bothers you and
ultimately what ultimately what I found
is it's not so much eating sugar too
much obviously messes me up but on the
days that I'll eat bread the next day I
feel foggy and groggy
yeah I mean it all affects you 90 of
your neurotransmitters are in your
intestines right so obviously what we
eat is related to our brains that's why
people with irritable bowel syndrome
take your uh antidepressants because
it's they're they're one of the same
yeah and this is why a lot of uh the gut
irregate a lot of the gut problems are
correlated with a lot of people taking
their ssris and antidepressants as well
and and there there's been something
happening within our food industry that
is absolutely incredibly worrisome
especially when it comes to chronic
diseases that are becoming more and more
common obesity obesity rates have gone
up 30 in the last 20 years meanwhile
meanwhile our calorie intake didn't
really change that much so people have
to start asking themselves What What In
the world's really going on here what do
you make of all this what do you think
from being inside the industry is
responsible for a lot of this yeah it is
it's what the food is made up of it's
obviously the food deserts too you look
in a lot of these inner cities they have
no access to Whole Foods real foods so
they're eating empty calories
um so even if you look at it on a kind
of a calorie by calorie base there's
there's superfoods and there's effective
calories and then there's just kind of
empty calories that that ultimately
affect the mind which is what probably
what you were feeling the next day and
that's a common that's a common feeling
I think that people come down on on this
notion this gluten-free movement as
being just this kind of California
hippie left-wing thing I think there is
a genuine
um issue in our food system that's
leading people to have more sensitivity
to gluten is what it is I mean that
could be conspiratorial and I could pin
it to certain vaccines or I could just
say it's the you know preponderance of
of hidden chemicals in our food
specifically glyphosate I'm sure you
guys know yeah all the time they use it
as a desiccant on wheat if your wheat's
not organic uh what they'll do is
they'll spray it on there throughout the
course of the wheat's life to prevent I
think it's a fungicide or is it a is it
a herbicide or it's an herbicide Roundup
yeah so make sure your favorite
pesticide but then they go in right
before they're about to harvest it and
to dry out the wheat they hit it with
Roundup again is a desiccant and then
they harvest it really quick quick
that's disgusting and now Bill Gates is
making super glycer fate as of course
the glycophate and and the the bacteria
resistance is starting to build up
against it and not being as effective so
now they're doing a stronger version of
glycophate and this is the latest corn
video that Bill Gates kind of rolled out
there recently with him sucking down on
the corn cob uh and and when children
you know dancing and uh and singing
behind you know you know what they
originally used glyphosate for and it
started in the Reagan Administration and
they actually were using it they would
spray Colombian cocaine um Farms with
the glyphosate to kill it and then it
would sadly it would leach into the
water system would leap leach into the
surrounding communities which are like
smaller communities or indigenous
communities and then they saw 10 15
years later a lot of those people
started developing different Cancers and
all these Health ailments but it was
used by the US government to stop it was
part of the drug war yeah now it's in
all of our food yeah I'd rather have the
cocaine in our food
yeah might as well come on coke who was
it was it Elon musker tweeted that yeah
yeah you bring back Coke to yeah buy
coke to put the cocaine back in it that
was another another chemical well I
don't want to talk right now there's a
whole bunch of garbage that they put in
uh in our food and everybody eats it
that's another thing too we we have
these glass bottles we used to we have a
bunch of those plastic water bottles I
see you're drinking over there but we
also have uh we started buying a bunch
of glass bottles to get away from the
plastic ones because of the phthalates
the the pcbs or the the pfas or whatever
there's just like it's crazy I kind of
feel like we look back on history and
we're like did you know they used to
drink Mercury to to deal with syphilis
or whatever in 50 to 100 years they're
gonna be like could you imagine they
were actually using plastic for their
food how messed up is that it's such a
good point you are entirely correct we
will so much of what we're doing right
now we're gonna look back on and be like
isn't that crazy which is funny because
during covet everything was just agreed
upon on as pure fact you can't question
it trust the science okay so let's start
I just want to bring up one more Point
especially when it comes to
microplastics that are now being found
in people's lungs and blood this is
something that of course is also a huge
uh disrupter of your hormone system and
this is why a lot of people think that
sperm levels and testosterone levels
have gone down so so much dramatically
within the last few years is there I
mean there's no way of stopping it China
just keeps getting all the plastic
dumping it into the ocean uh the United
States just essentially just started
doing the same thing
um The Masks again lots of plastic just
being thrown out there people breathing
it in sucking sucking all the plastic
down there is there a way of of even
avoiding this plastic I mean we try to
do uh you know glass bottles but at the
same time everything else is in plastic
all the food is wrapped in plastic all
the cookware is is laced with plastic
all the things are non-stick plastic is
there is there a way of avoiding any of
this craziness because like I'm just I'm
just looking at everything that's
happening I'm like I mean there's no way
of stopping it dude I mean I use bamboo
to cook my food Etc and you can use like
a skillet you know you can there's
things you can do that are like well
yeah I have a cast iron skillet as well
but then you know the food comes
packaged in plastic right that's just
like no I totally understand don't
understand yeah am I being too paranoid
here or do you like what are you seeing
from your observations you know I don't
know
um in terms of where it's coming from in
that particular scenario right so if we
have all these micro Plastics that are
in our lungs that's we're breathing that
in so is that does that come from food
does it come from cooking does it come
from heat I just I have no idea I mean
it's clearly it's an issue
um but it's you know it's one of those
issues that's used as a hammer in
certain circumstances and ignored in
other circumstances yeah I'll I'll put
it this way Luke um we usually have to
go to farms uh I believe it was what
like a hundred years ago the average
family owned a cow or something like
that like cows were very common a family
would have the family cow when you
wanted meat there wasn't plastic but you
had to go to a farm you'd go to a
butcher you can still do those things
it's just that there's a convenient
location with plastic wrapped food for
you and so we just choose to go there
but look man we're lucky out here maybe
even like five miles away there's a farm
a Farm Stand it's a little building and
when you when you go in there get the
meat it's it's in like wax paper it's in
like you know Deli wrapped wax paper and
then they hand it to you it's frozen and
you bring it home and you you peel a
sticker It's Paper open it up
farm fresh meat right there on the spot
nope no plastics grass-fed good stuff a
lot of the papers have plastic in them a
lot of the receipts have plastic in them
my dream now is to have a cow sorry Ian
you had something else you wanted I'm
wearing plastic glasses on my face it's
pretty gross probably leaching into my
head as I'm speaking I've been thinking
that a little esoterically like if the
Earth is an organism and they say like
it'll if it doesn't like the life on it
it'll kill it all with like a flood like
it'll flood itself and wipe out all the
life that's been poisoning its surface
or it'll bring an asteroid a meteoroid
or something I think also what the Earth
would do this is obviously it's kind of
somewhat silly to think of the Earth as
a living organism but let's just say it
is that it would wipe out Humanity by
making it sterile and we're kind of
doing that to ourselves with plastics
and hormones and chemicals herbicides in
our water supply it's it's decreasing
the fertility rates and so it's it's
another way to wipe out a species is
through infertility I'd never thought of
that before we don't need a flood or an
asteroid this time we just got to be
really careful about what we consume but
I mean good question Luke I think maybe
the future is
graphene getting away from these weird
oil-based carbons and trying to make
something a little more stable like
diamond packaging what if the graphene
is worse than all the other Plastics and
leeches even more and then it goes into
our bloodstream you got to find ways for
it not to Leach that's key like I don't
know if you had like like malleable
Diamond plastic like if it was like
diamond pure carbon and it was like
crumpleable diamond if that would not
Leach I mean I think you could find ways
to not leech could we be proactive
though and actually make the packaging
out of testosterone oh something edible
or like vitamin C we're thinking on the
defense here we gotta be we got there
there's a there's a store uh not far
away from here that they print their
receipts on like vitamin C receipts and
there's no plastics so I didn't see yes
vitamin C uh moms moms supermarkets do
that yeah the the receipts are not made
of out of plastic they're like hey we
have vitamin C uh um receipts here you
can eat it
um I asked him if I could they're like
no but uh you know the plastic
especially from the receipts it does
Leach does have they're like yes your
purchase record and we'll see if we let
you out of the store but every time I'm
there I'm like hey this is pretty cool
that you guys are doing this um the
receipt's like particularly bad or they
have cancer causing chemicals in them is
that the reason why well they're they're
uh made out of plastic that leeches
right I got to see some documents on
this vitamin C receipt because this is
sounding yeah I've never heard of that
you got to show up to Mom's uh the
supermarket in there right now is it
like a huge chain moms I think so
they're pretty great though yeah I like
going there I got Farm Fresh Cream for
my coffee real grass-fed stuff expires
real quick like it's supposed to so just
to ask you because you're in the food
industry did you notice the the level of
food kind of going down throughout the
throughout the last few years like did
you see the quality being an issue or
you know what's the kind of inside
baseball when it comes to procuring a
lot of food for your restaurants yeah
well the trajectory has already been on
a downward spiral just in general in
terms of quality of food and it follows
look at the quality of any everything
right
um but the uh over the since the
pandemic Yeah it's gotten really bad
because number one the supply chain
issues number two our relationship with
China and I think people don't realize
how much we rely on other countries for
our food so our food system is not just
incredibly vulnerable and it's not
domestic but it's also I mean it's
questionable when you're getting food
from another place that you don't know
how they're harvesting raising rearing
the husbandry behind their food so yeah
the answer is of course take the extra
time that's a great point that Tim makes
is that you if you take the extra time
you actually can go find that butcher
you know that that fish monger whoever
it is to actually try and understand
where your food is coming from I know it
sounds like a cliche from a wholesale
perspective it's much easier for me as a
restaurateur because I can kind of cut
out a couple kinks in that chain of
custody but consumers can do that too
and this is the point I've been making
since inflation has gotten so bad it's
incumbent upon consumers to create a
relationship with a restaurateur not
just this isn't kind of self self
filling here because then you can
piggyback on their orders and their
products I love it when customers come
to me and say hey can you throw five
extra pounds on the order of broccoli
that you're getting and then I buy more
which gives me better economies of scale
my customer gets raw products at a much
lower you know value which puts more
money in their pockets that they
hypothetically could spend at my
restaurant or another Community
restaurant I mean that's the notion of
comparative advantage and you know what
that's doing is actually cutting out the
Walmart to the world that's cutting out
a lot of these other businesses I think
someone should develop an app to
facilitate customers piggybacking off of
restaurant tours purchases I completely
agree well there's also a lot of
monopolies that I think cause a lot of
problems in the industry I think it's
estimated that there's only 10 companies
that produce 90 percent of the food in
the United States and when you have so
many few big multinational Industries
controlling a lot of this uh you know
many times profit is incentivized over
of course offering a product that's
actually good or or healthy or actually
going to be helping people in the long
term because a lot of the times it's not
incentivized to do so and I think also
behind the scenes there's a bigger
agenda to try to poison people with the
release of glycophate with the release
of seed oils making them a lot cheaper
with government subsidies knowing that
the end result will be more unhealthy
people which will be dependent on
government and therefore government is
doing this according to my own personal
opinion isn't uh like the wrong majority
of food from Cisco from all these
restaurants yes Cisco U.S Foods um you
know they're two of the biggest players
out there actually their their merger
was broken down by an Anti-Trust lawsuit
which is surprising but then it would
have been just one Behemoth um running
all the food but how does that work what
does Cisco do are they a distributor or
they're like they're a wholesaler and a
distributor so what they're going to do
is they're going to aggregate all the
products and then they're going to
distribute it to all the restaurants
venues you name it um so it's just
massive purchasing power wow yeah I mean
it is huge and and it's it's for me
um you know when it comes to trying to
grow a business and scale good I
consider what we were doing from a
sustainability perspective a good
business and using the little guys
because we mandated that as part of our
franchise system it was virtually
economically impossible to do so and to
avoid the ciscos and the U.S foods of
the world and ultimately my franchisees
ended up using those guys and I couldn't
stop them from using it because you
can't force them to lose money right and
then the big guys win they always do
what's this new lawsuit you said if your
franchisee does something Elite like I
didn't get the full story it's called
The Joint employer it's called The Joint
employer Rule and it was actually set
forth during the Obama Administration it
was overturned during the Trump
Administration and then it was put back
in place um under the new abide
Administration and what it basically um
conjects is that if you are a franchisor
let's say I sell a franchise to you
you're all the way out here you're
running the franchise and you're
mistreating your employees I've just
licensed you my brand I don't run your
business you run your business I have
absolutely nothing to do with it let's
say you short pay one of your employees
your employee sues you they sue me too
I'm in the lawsuit even though I have
nothing to do with it it pierces that
corporate veil between the franchisee
and the franchisor giving responsibility
to the bigger guy that doesn't sound
like a functional system yeah and
originally it was set forth by
McDonald's it was a McDonald's lawsuit
because they said that McDonald's was
trying to stop the unions from working
with local franchisees and then there
was a lot of issues in lawsuits they
went after the whoever the had the
biggest bank okay so certain level of
Corporations well anyway that's an
interesting conversation do you how did
you guys navigate like because you said
2011 is when you opened your first food
cart and so 11 years later you got 60 60
restaurants uh so it was yeah ten years
later we had 40 couple different kinds
how did you create such explosive growth
was it my my hopefully what are you
going to say as good ingredients but
tell me about like what did you
prioritize to get there well actually it
was pretty simple formula so what we
said is my the whole entire mission was
to get people to eat more Seafood but
more of the right types of seafood so we
were sourcing 100
um percent sustainably caught raised
Farm seafood and then all of our
ingredients we were the first four star
Green certified restaurant we were
actually kind of at the Forefront of
green
um so I you know I'm like that that that
um you know kind of weird hippie space
but we sent that we we stuck with our
message we're true to it we weren't
green washing ninety percent of the
businesses now that use all that
language they're not true to it we're
true to it and sustainability tastes
better right and that's what people need
to realize is that at higher quality
when it comes to food and sustainability
it does actually taste better and then
that was it I mean it's a real simple
formula just good food I'll say one
thing you know Papa John's better
ingredients the company did Papa John
dirty but actually look at their
ingredients and it's it's true and I you
know I love this I looked at the the
ingredients for like Pizza Hut their
crust has Splenda in it yeah yeah why
then you look at dominoes and Domino's
isn't as bad but they've got you like
you'll see like words you can't
pronounce but then you look at like Papa
John's and it's like whole wheat water
yeast you know the sauce tomatoes sugar
you know the cheese part skim milk
whatever it's like wow really is like
very very basic stuff we got these
protein bars the epic epic protein bars
which is meat got them because the
ingredients it's like beef garlic
paprika and then the only thing that's
weird is like the lactic acid thing and
I'm like I know what that is it doesn't
freaked me out and it's like it's pretty
good stuff man you hear about it let's
uh we gotta go to Super Chat sorry uh
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're one of a members only
uncensored show for you tonight you
don't want to miss it let's read some of
these messages
daybob says please get gormelt's owner
that was rated Friday uh he actually
sent me a message uh we read it on the
show he sent me another message so I'll
be in touch and that'll be really great
all right Max Reddick says Tim I hear a
lot of people on the left saying the DHS
colluding with big Tech start under the
Trump Administration as a gotcha
thoughts
I'm pretty sure it did didn't it yeah he
passed the law that allowed the DHS to
do a lot of this stuff to foreign and
then it came back to haunt him yeah yeah
what a funny thing for Republicans to
keep doing these things yeah and and you
know also the gain of function work that
Donald Trump approved that was banned
under Obama oh yeah that really did have
an effect here all right uplift actual
says Trump's post was taken out of
context he was saying if the
establishment can do the things they do
they will terminate rules regulations
and amendments including the ones in the
Constitution we didn't go over this
story today this is where Trump said
something about what what we can talk
about this one for the members only
because we you know what was the quote
exactly they're referencing down it's a
long quote I wouldn't be able to just
read it off of my head but it was
something the effect of you know the
rules being changed or something
all right Amazon says Cosmic Garth seems
more like a Bard to me yeah sometimes I
feel like that myself thank you also a
charismatic sorcerer that uses a musical
instrument to empower their spells uh
Bard or even to cast them culture
abduction says I have a friend who lives
in the area where the substation is in
North Carolina and he's chilling because
he has chickens he's actually he's he's
chilling because he has chickens he's
actually bragging about it uh well you
know chickens are legit they they can
handle the cold weather they do their
own thing they make more of themselves
that's the crazy thing you get some
chickens you put them out there food and
water they make more of themselves and
then you eat the extras yeah it's
fantastic and you eat their butt Bounty
wonderful butt Bounty just clean the
poop off yeah you know what I really
love I especially love chicken dishes
that have chicken and egg like Pad Thai
because there's something just like very
like
apex predator about that yeah right
we're eating your egg and you with the
same thing it's kind of crazy
Max Redix has him I turned 30 on the
22nd of this month what's the likelihood
as a member that I could come on the
show to make my birthday wish come true
or name a price probably not likely at
all dude sorry to say it happy birthday
happy birthday though especially with
all the security stuff going on we it's
getting crazy out here man hey I'm 32
shout out dude
Mr Brightside is it Mr Brightside says
is yay punk rock for offending everyone
yes he is
yeah um I don't know if I mean if he
actually believes this stuff
then it's not really punk rock if he's
just trying to shock the system then
okay but um didn't Sid Vicious he wore a
swastika all the time or something like
that yeah yeah but it was different than
I was trying to I mean that's where the
the whole gods of the queen thing and
they were saying you know to hell with
that basically
Paige young says did yay just get
suspended on Twitter no he was spended
last week
there you go
posting a picture I don't know I thought
he was going to get suspended for saying
that he was going to let Milo and Nick
use his Twitter account I don't know if
there's ever confirmed that he did that
but that's a band evasion if he did that
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim we needed
your 4 pm video the truth is the truth
yes I'm optimistic we're moving in the
right direction but it's still going to
be an uphill battle
yeah basically at 4 P.M I talked about
similar things you know Elon saying he's
fearing for his life talked about what
happened here and you know the general
idea was
around like I don't know 2 30 I was on a
phone call with a lawyer
and I'm asking him like what is the
legal remedy to all of these things and
they were like nothing there isn't one
you know it's like they give you the run
around they say look here's what we can
do for you I'm like you can't do
anything you literally can do nothing
there's no civil action there's no
criminal action the government has
become completely impotent or they've
always been as Ian pointed out earlier
they've always been maybe they've never
actually been able to deal with crime it
really is the threat of force that keeps
us safe not the actual ideally there is
none no Force being implemented and what
I think is when antifa random muck
smashing stuff burning things down and
murdering people the veil shattered and
now all of a sudden criminals are just
like nothing matters it's a lot of times
why regimes will do huge crackdowns if
there's even an inkling of an uprising
because you do it hard and fast and then
they stop is the idea because you can't
handle a big wide spread Uprising nobody
can nervous sip says For the Love of
everything McDonald's burgers are not
pre-made it takes them 30 seconds to
assemble wrong
I'm not saying they get him out of a
freezer box with the thing I'm saying
when you walk into McDonald's there is a
rack with heat lamps and the burgers are
sitting in it already
what they'll do is they'll make us there
are certain burgers that sell very
quickly like Big Macs they'll make it
usually sells within a minute or two the
point is if Donald Trump were to go into
McDonald's and say I would like when Big
Mac make it the biggest the biggest Mac
then someone's gonna take oh I'll make
this Big Mac for him and spit on it but
if he walks in and under the heat lamp
is a burger that had been made before he
walked in then he gets a burger made to
standard
that's how it goes
kalkai says the Earth cannot be
determined to be flat because you are
too small a sufficiently relativistic
small object on a large sphere observe
to generate the geometry the sphere
turns into a flat object thank you for
that enlightening information as to why
the world is not flat
appreciate it it was it because we would
fly off is that what he said no no
because uh you offended Ian with that
comment yeah Sergeant bucks says I run a
catering company in Washington lockdown
rules were borked weddings could be up
to 200 people six feet apart but if food
was available the cap was 50. local
chains were were cleared to do delivery
but I was told to close up shop
maybe when you look at these things you
realize it clearly wasn't about covid it
was about limiting human expansion and
consumption and the New York Times wrote
an article saying the Earth is healing
then they started talking about climate
lockdowns to save the planet yeah and uh
the rest is history yeah what happened
in hospitals and funerals was absolutely
inhumane the way people were pushed away
from their family members when they were
leaving this earth when when people were
trying to hug each other during a
funeral there's people screaming at them
that was evil absolutely evil what we
saw and went through
David Todd says Tim if you read tweet 21
and 22 together I believe Matt taibi's
no government involvement portion is
specifically about Twitter using the
Hacked materials policy to censor
essentially the government never
confirmed it was hacked for Twitter to
use that policy I see what you're saying
however if the DHS and FBI reached out
to Twitter and said specifically hey
hack materials are coming with Hunter
Biden involvement
and then they started censoring that
that's that is direct and overt
government involvement and that
information was available
sfc retired says it's called a home
invasion bro yes uh that's correct it's
a home invasion so uh my home was
invaded this morning I was not there
um you know keep them guessing they they
they're posing an address claiming it's
my house it's not my house they're
posting a picture that Heavens it's not
the it's not even the same address
they're posting so these people are
stupid but uh you know I I worry for the
people who who come to these places we
have armed security please do not show
up here under any circumstances without
authorization that's just that's just
plain and simple man yeah it's a bad
idea
very bad
Jen Desai says Miranda Devine at New
York Post reported FBI was monitoring
giuliani's emails in regards to the
laptop which led them to monitor her
emails she has the most extensive
reporting on the laptop from hell
uh we read we've read a lot about it man
yeah
what do we have here
Cal is back saying those who conduct
violence in the name of someone else's
Free Speech should be the definition of
hate speech there's nothing forcing you
to listen to an individual extra
punishment for criminals
well there you go no criminals
all right where are we at
TD says the FBI spot on giuliani's cloud
shop owner gave laptop to G Elon don't
want to be Seth richt I'm from Frederick
hope y'all hit up Spook Hill I don't
know what that is I don't know what that
is and it's epsteined sorry that's Elon
didn't want to be epsteined although uh
there's a possibility you know the Seth
Rich verb may work they said it was a
robbery gone wrong or something that
effect yeah and um you know completely
unrelated Seth rich just you know just
so you know one way they could get rid
of someone is to do a staged robbery you
know and then they could do that as a
robbery robberies happen completely
unrelated Seth rich
anyway and I I mean it literally I'm
just saying you know just
you know or Epstein
there's many ways to do it there is
there's many ways for people to or a
heart attack gone as you've mentioned
yeah but uh you know unrelated or just
making me hate reality enough that I do
it to myself oh well you see what's we
have that other story you hear about
what's going on in Canada
some some paralympian called the
government being like I need a stair
lift and they're like we can kill you
they offered her medical assistance and
dying instead of just getting her the
wheelchair lift for her stairs yeah
amazing we've hit a new level yeah yeah
those that want to be here the ones that
will be here in Germany they have a
similar policy but you need to have a
you need to be vaccinated in order to be
wait what yeah yes it's too dangerous
otherwise I tweeted it today it was a it
was an article from 2021
yep in Germany if you want to be
euthanized you have to be vaccinated
first I think there are people whose
brains stopped working or maybe never
worked at all they say that the death
would be so much worse if you weren't
vaccinated there's a lot of jokes I can
no here's in trouble that I'm not going
to say here in Canada they get they send
you a device yeah they send you a
medical assistance and dying device yeah
it's wild and then you like I guess get
at your house and let them know it's
happening and then you kill yourself and
they come collect the body or something
hey it's North America we like that DIY
you know that's crazy man
alahad says Tim please give this 20 to
Ian he's the best part of IRL makes
listening to such heavy topics easier no
Ian we pee in remember rolling a 20 in a
vacuum is there no joy it's all about
friendship so about people seeing you
roll that 20 that's what it's all about
that's true if you're sitting in your
room and you roll the 20 side and got a
20 you'd look around and if a 20-sided
die is rolled in an empty game shop was
the 20 rolled at all good question
no that's actually a really good point
about Humanity in general everything we
do Jeremy boring was talking about this
windows in the show everything we do is
for The Human Experience so without
humans what's the point of anything we
do so what you do is for humans someone
needs to tell Bill Gates that
immediately bill you need to listen to
this now
MIT fomo 2 says eat more Seafood I love
that
that's awesome whenever I get a steak
they do the scallops on the side you can
get the
accompaniments I've been so concerned
with Mercury that I have avoided bottom
feeding Seafood Lobster shellfish I mean
all shellfish Bottom Feeders essentially
I would say sardines are some of the
most healthiest things you could have
but what what do you think is the most
healthiest Seafood you could have uh
sardines and oysters okay but if you're
thinking of mercury just look at the
trophic scale think of the high the high
Predators because they eat down the
Petrovic scale so anything small
medium-sized fish no traceable levels of
mercury anything on the higher end yes
they're going to have more traceable
levels of mercury but who's eating
swordfish every single night yeah
tuna also is pretty big and it's pretty
massive people don't understand a huge
specific albacore tuna um they reproduce
at six months and they have no traceable
levels of mercury a beautiful locally
caught U.S rate US um wild fish see I
just love sardines and oysters yeah but
it's called bio amplification when a
animal eats another animal and gets all
its style accumulation there's uh scams
where you try to order fresh salmon and
you'll say you want like wild you want
wild salmon right from you know Alaskan
or whatever and what they do is they
have like brand labels wild brand or
something like that and you're actually
getting farmed salmon that's named wild
salmon not really hot salmon yeah that's
crazy I know yeah yeah that's right so I
I I could tell you a story about that
but I don't want to upset any sponsors
but I will say this
um that there is a something called
stock fortification where you actually
will start fishing hatcheries and
release it into wild it was originally
established by the government in order
to help stocks that were declining and
there are a lot of Fisheries that
fortify their stocks releasing in the
wild and then legally you can label it
as wild wow so it's kind of a
controversial subject but they do the I
would say upwards of 80 of salmon is
mislabeled in the restaurant industry
have you heard of iron fertilization are
you familiar with the tech the
technology they they take iron oxide
dust and put it in the ocean and then it
causes Plankton to to bloom because
Plankton uses the iron oxide and then
they saw this fish the Plankton is fish
food huge regrowths of fish the fish
populations rebloom if you really want
wild salmon if you really want to help
the environment you'd be doing that
instead of all the other wacky stuff
that they're trying to propose because
when you look at that solution what you
mentioned it's the end-all be-all when
it comes to Bringing life back to the
oceans the Earth does it to itself you
see the river of blood in Antarctica
it's this iron just just iron Waters
just flushing into the ocean because it
looks like it's preparing to flood
itself so it wants to iron up the water
so that we can have Plankton and fish
yeah but what you brought up is key and
important for a lot of people to pick up
Beavis McLean says Tim you are right in
pushing back against police who do not
respect the Constitution I do have an
idea that will help expose corruption
with the police departments however I'll
have to hire Ian as a tech consultant
let me know if you're interested
that's a very very very big ask what's
the I don't know what's the data hit me
on Twitter we're on mines
I don't want to get involved in any
legal disputes right now Aaron Brandt
says hope all is okay keep on everybody
is fine after uh the incident in the
morning nobody got hurt uh not even the
bad guys and you know I had a bunch of
people messaging me or like tweeting at
me being like you shouldn't have missed
and I was like I wasn't there
um but there is a very serious question
about the you know the legal issues
arounding it surrounding it and
I think you just don't mess around if
someone breaks into your house
especially with all the threats we've
been getting no one here should be
assuming that the person breaking in has
good intentions you know is that what's
the protocol a home defense protocol is
it different in every state every
Community like you warn them you like
retreat it it is different everywhere
um West Virginia has some of the best
laws uh I know Texas has a good laws
Florida does New Jersey has like some of
the worst yeah surprisingly not the
worst uh Maryland is better than New
Jersey in most States you know with New
Jersey when I was told by the cops is
that if someone breaks in and you kill
them you will be arrested and charged
with their murder like there's no
question like unless you're a special
person and you know but they were like
the uh castle doctrine idea this is is
an affirmative defense so after you're
arrested and charged you can plead to
the court I was defending myself granted
it really depends on the cops too it's a
political climate I think with a place
like New Jersey a criminal could be
breaking into your house they could be a
convicted rapist and if you killed them
a bunch of activists would show up
saying you didn't have to and then you
get arrested and that's just how it's
gonna that's how to go down West
Virginia on the other hand
someone breaks into your house there's
gonna be like who in their right mind
would break into a house in West
Virginia yeah I don't even want to step
on people's property without them
knowing I'm there oh yeah you just don't
I don't so West Virginia is not the
craziest place you can't just like kill
a random person who's on your property
but um you have a lot more legal
protections if they're on your property
and threatening you in some way right
whereas in Maryland if they enter your
property you have no grounds whatsoever
to defend yourself in any capacity until
you Retreat to your home right and then
once you're in your home if they try to
break in then you if just trying to
break in so if they try and jiggle the
handle they shoulder the door now you're
you're entitled to uh I'm not a lawyer
this is just what I was reading on the
internet which is probably not true so
I'll just make sure that's clear so this
is another thing about the South African
situation is there's a duty to retreat
laws in South Africa as well so if the
person's in your house but they're not
making any threat on your life directly
you're still unable to stop or impede
them from doing what they're doing it's
uh it's wild if personal family stories
about that but I won't say anything rest
in peace so far but but doesn't that
just result in everyone yelling he's
coming right for me and you know before
they uh yeah but it's it's where they
hire private security in the first place
I don't know if this is true or not but
I remember reading a story about how
like in China if you injure someone
you're on the hook for the rest of their
lives so they'll just murder the person
so like if someone is driving their car
and they hit a person they'll go oh crap
go out and just murder him yes because
yeah because you have a there's a duty
you can't go if you're if someone's
injured or dies while they've been
injured and you were part of like their
safety or like helping them out it would
be like oh you were the person who
caused their death because the story is
that like you're in you're driving your
car and you hit somebody now their legs
are broken you are on the hook for life
for their financial problems even so
even if you even if you were trying to
help somebody that's been injured and
yeah and you go and try and help them
and offer them assistance anyway you're
now tied into it right because of that
though so nobody else and then someone
so like someone will hit someone with a
car and then go well better kill him yes
there was that horrible video that went
viral like six months ago of the girl
that got run over and China and and it
went for like five minutes of just
everyone walking by driving oh no
there's compilation videos of that that
just happening over and over and over
again so that's just like horrible
things and people just ignoring it
because Chinese law is if they get
involved they touch the person which
then breaks their ankle a little bit
more they're now responsible what it
sounds like yeah I didn't know that I
actually watched that video hoping it
was fake no only find out it wasn't and
and I needed a reason right because we
do when you're not like that and now you
just explained that must be why it's
written into the law yeah there's no
good there's no Good Samaritan law if
you help out and they die and they're
injured anyway you're on the hook for
life it's crazy
waffle sense that says FBI goes after
people for justice so that citizens
don't the FBI likes when right-wingers
are gone after and they like when
right-wingers retaliate so they do
nothing I'm sure some FBI guys are okay
yeah I think so I think there's some but
I think at the highest level they're
just they're never going to do it you
know they're never going to do their job
yeah yeah just all nonsense there you go
yeah you you your blood would curdle if
you knew what was going on behind the
scenes what we can and can't talk about
all right Sean says I followed the food
pyramid diet and cardio for years and
couldn't lose weight I gave high fat
diet and one high intensity workout a
week a try and lost over a hundred a
hundred pounds the experts are killing
us holy crap man that food pyramid is
one of the biggest lies ever it's a it's
like it tells me it tells you eat a big
old bowl of pasta like just a ton of
carbs it's freaking nuts it is an
economic model that's an economic model
it was meant to allow the US to produce
more corn and more wheat in order to
grow the economy at the time when it was
first in the state it has nothing to do
with health and I know that because I
have an econ degree it has nothing to do
with food or health whatsoever the
craziest thing is I did this this
calculator it was like it was like how
much protein should I eat calculator and
it said that I should be eating 400
carbs per day and like 63 grams of
protein and I was like that sounds
insane I've been eating I've been eating
like 40 to 50 carbs no not even that
much I think today I probably had about
30 carbs and I feel like a million bucks
30 grams yeah I was skating I posted I
posted a clip to Instagram and me just
skating you look good that was a big
improvement from two years ago I just I
saw it and I realized I hadn't seen you
skate in a while uptake what how do you
get your carbs uh I had Lobster biscuit
had cane sugar in it not not too happy
about that because it definitely did not
need it lobster bisque is creamy and
delicious the tomatoes have sugar
already and I looked at the back and I
saw how many carbs were in it I was like
yeah do you guys Whole Foods man what
are you doing do you use alternate 50
carbs in this thing a Lobster biscuit do
you use all kinds of sugars like what
kind of sugars do you guys use yeah I'll
use natural sugars I mean I like monk
fruit sugar but normally as you say I
mean food Tomatoes right foods have
enough sugar in them when it comes to
Seafood Lobster is naturally sweet same
with scallops that's why scallops taste
like candy best thing ever is angels on
horseback scallops wrapped in bacon
that's why people love sweet and you
know kind of salty and salty and Meaty
um I like buttering my steak Yeah Yeah I
didn't know that was a thing until Luke
did it and I was like what are you
putting butter and he's like yeah and I
was like oh yeah yeah and I asked the
waiter I was like am I supposed to but
it's like yes I was like oh my god well
compound butter is what like I try and
give these simple ways to make your food
that much better if you actually just
take your butter put it at room
temperature throw in Dijon mustard
Sherry vinegar fresh herbs garlic and
some shallots whatever your other
favorite ingredients are put it back in
the fridge throw that compound butter on
all your food throw it in your cereal
heck why not could we go to the kitchen
after this yeah and do the after show in
the kitchen seriously let's okay let's
get one of the cameras and let's record
something in the kitchen let's cook
something I'll just pull open the fridge
and whatever is there we'll create a
meal out of it I got I I got I got raw
milk I got beef liver I got a whole
bunch I got I got oh Tallow I got actual
butter we could we could make something
happen you have beef liver huh so do you
have do you have steroids
we gotta talk about him we got a bunch
of fresh eggs from chickens oh yeah yeah
yeah with the poop still on them yeah
yeah that's legit yeah the poop is still
there uh but yeah in response to the the
food pyramid it you know it's it's
almost as if the government wants you
fat and unhealthy one whether or not
we'd make it make cooking tonight which
I'm open to we should do a collaboration
in the future and do some after show
grab the camera go to the kitchen open
the fridge you guys Bears let's go from
there well you're expanding your culture
content and food is uh love everybody
loves food unification but since it's my
idea I got to eat it we got to see if
sure we could that'd be great actually
be very fun we can see if there's a
camera available uh I guess people who
are listening put one in the chat if you
want to see uh uh if you're down to like
make some food or something I don't want
to put you on the spot why not okay
we're ready
I'll put a mouse in my pocket whatever
you got I have the skillet I have
everything all right uh Albert Albie Dam
says Ian what's so great about useless
graphene
oh well how much time you got it's 9 54.
I can give you about 30 seconds did you
see his shirt
um it's a great shirt it's 200 times
stronger than steel by weight so it's
fantastic just structurally as a
building material it's more conductive
than copper it's deformable like paper
so you can make clothing out of it you
can make wallpaper out of it uh it's
pure carbon you make space elevator
tethers out of it I think that's the
ideas we're gonna be making our tethers
for our space elevators out of graphene
if you build it in the right it's really
the Fino structure this hexagonal
honeycomb structure so you have borophy
and it's Boron you don't need just
carbon so there's there's this
compressive force in this lattice that's
pretty fantastic and I think if you
layer a property you'll be able to make
wiring that can conduct and capacitate
electricity
uh lightning lightning electricity do
you think uh about a half an hour 40
minutes is enough time to make something
yeah yeah all right all right so it'll
be we'll just film it raw yeah because
otherwise we don't have time to edit and
then we'll just put the whole thing up
we'll see if someone's available to film
and just we'll go down film and we'll
just do like a raw behind the scenes
food that'd be cool yeah the only thing
I ate today I had two protein bars and a
and a bowl of lobster bisque I just had
coffee I had nothing yeah coffee
and I'm like sitting there thinking like
man I probably needs to eat food I'm not
even I had an apple I had an apple
chicken liver
and beef with peppers oh it sounds
amazing and then fruit in the morning
hey Andrew do you like red pepper or
green pepper better green pepper for
like cheesy fatty things just because
it's a little bit more vegetal and then
red pepper for raw or you know salad
type dishes I love those those those
Peppers that Cara makes
the the bacon wrapped cream cheese
jalapenos stuff I just like ate like 15
of them when she made them last it's a
great use of pepper man cheese and wrap
it yep Oh man give it a grill tastes so
good man I'm getting hungry what's going
on all right my plan has worked
Rolling Crest says I love gourmelts I
mean even the name is making me hungry
you just wanna wanna go eat there yeah
go to go to go to Fredericksburg
Virginia and eat at Gore melts do it
all right Seth weather says eat steak
lift weights be uncensorable screw the
government Seth weathers all right good
advice that's very good right advice
what's uh I forget your website Seth
Brandon wrapp is that what it was
Brandon rapping or something you want to
check that out real quick is it Brandon
yes that's the guy who sells like the
different like Christmas wrapping yeah
let's go Brandon wrapping paper which is
like the best thing to get a family
member I just yeah yeah yeah there was a
I was at the casino like this weekend
and there was a guy named Brandon and
the old guy's next to me were like let's
go Brandon and then they look each other
and started laughing and then I just
started laughing like yeah that's right
is this the that's a wrap yeah I'm
trying to find it on the let's go
Brandon wrapping paper yeah I'm a fly
oh Freedom my heel what is that go for
it I'll let you my heel says Ah Mercury
sweetest of the transition metals hmm
what's around that's right
David Todd says when I was a teen
working at Office Max we sold lifetime
warranty tables lifetime warranty was
the brand name and it had a one month
warranty wow that is brilliant yeah
there's there's companies called like
homemade ice cream you know hand crafted
and it's just like it's brand it's
ridiculous that's such crap I mean that
is Just sh gosh the law should protect
people from misleading their uh they're
targeted their customer base what do you
think should should people be allowed to
sell real organic fruit and not tell you
that it's actually glyphosate or
whatever it was a glycember glyphosate
but it's like hey our brand name is
called real organic and no glyphosate
fruit should they be allowed to do that
um I mean obviously the market would uh
correct itself and people would do the
test and people would see it and I don't
know it's a complex question there's
many different variables I automatically
I think that the problem would solve
itself and the scam would be exposed
like most scam M's usually are perhaps I
don't think that issue means
definitively there should be a
government regulation on it I'm just
saying the average person look I'll tell
you a story I went to a mall and they
were doing that you ever see those
Balance bracelets oh yeah it's it's it's
it's a con and I'm surprised they're
allowed to sell these things they sell
you these bracelets and they tell you it
improves your core strength it's got a
reverse ion charge blah blah blah and
then they use a center of gravity
illusion to manipulate you into thinking
it works what they do is they have you
stand with your feet together and put
your arms out and they'll put their hand
on your arm and pull slightly down to
the right away from your center of
gravity you'll fall over instantly then
they'll say now put on the Power Band
and when you do they'll push into your
center of gravity and they can push down
as hard as they can as long as they go
slightly less and you won't fall and
they say wow look at this take it off
and I'll show you again and then they
knock you over it's a trick yeah and I'm
like how are they allowed to do this the
FTC you know what to Luke's Point
incompetent they would like go after
these companies find them they'd shut
down reopen do the exact same thing make
millions of dollars
so you know I guess they gave a good
college try but they were completely
ineffective at stopping the stuff wait
until you find out about big Pharma yeah
and what they're doing I spent 25
dollars for a bronze engraving of
Abraham Lincoln once they sent me a
penny wow is that true though
that's a good joke if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com I guess we're going to try
and cook something yes and just we'll
see if we can get like if the camera
guys are here we'll see if we can do
that and then do a special members only
uncensored and we can talk about the
stuff as you're cooking so it'll be
it'll be like a multi-faceted
conversation while we get some food to
eat so uh smash that like button
subscribe you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
everywhere Instagram Twitter at timcast
Chef Andrew Gould you want to shout
anything out
I just want to say thank you for having
me on I really appreciate it you can
follow me at uh on everything at chef
grueler at Andrew gruel or go to my
website which is chefgruel.com right on
Chef that was awesome thank you so much
for coming that was a great conversation
my website is Luke uncensored.com and I
usually do a lot of rants about health
cooking personal development working out
doing a lot of different stuff today I
did a video about how a lot of things
are screwed up in our society but that
doesn't mean you have to be luke
uncensored.com see you there for that
conversation and uh yeah because you
guys sign up that's why I'm here thanks
for having me follow me at Ian
crossland.net and you get through to any
of my social media accounts through
their YouTube Facebook Twitter mines the
list goes on Instagram check me out and
follow me anywhere good to see you guys
Andrew great to meet you buddy I'll ask
you more questions on the after show
about food and hey confirmation Seth
weathers it is freedomspeaksup.com
that's the website
freedomspeaksup.com you can get your
let's go Brandon wrapping paper there
Seth thanks for super chatting good to
hear from you buddy and I am at
search.com everywhere please follow me I
appreciate it I'll be in the comments
I'm always in the comments me answering
is at search.com is me no one else see
you there you know I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna go for it here uh the
incident this morning I now uh believe
more so was politically targeted uh
I I didn't see this message until now
but around nine o'clock we were swatted
and the cops are here so yeah uh well
actually they may have been here earlier
uh so I'm just checking my messages now
and uh there you go uh security dealt
with it so we we went we went we won a
period where we didn't report any of
this stuff was happening because people
kept telling us if you keep saying it
it'll keep happening and then it kept
happening anyway so I'm like no maybe
now we just need to let people know like
what's happening is actually very very
serious and it's escalating that's
that's the reality of what's been going
all you cops out there that are
listening thanks for being on the ball
with this one thanks for coming if you
guys were here earlier tonight doing
your job appreciate it yep all right
well uh I I I I I'm sure everything's
fine as well we have armed security but
uh we'll go cook some food so thanks for
hanging out and we will see you all uh
at timcast.com for whatever food we end
up eating yeah right on let's eat